What's the correct pronunciation of your
last name?
Dimmers.
Dimmers,
dimmers,
dimmers.
Works.
Ie.
Yes.
And we're like second podcast of 2016.
Phil,
how you feel about that?
I'm ecstatic.
Joy,
I can't even begin to thank you for
this.
Honestly,
if it wasn't for my having been on this
podcast two years ago and returning now
in a very timely manner,
I think I'd be a fish out of water.
What do you mean?
Well,
in terms of the cars that I sort of
represent and all the multiple lawsuits
that are levied against,
uh,
all the animal activists that you know,
that I'm amongst.
But let's explain to everybody who is
unfamiliar.
You,
uh,
had a lawsuit with a marine world used
to work for marine world marine.
Larry Marine land skews me,
which is like seaworld for Canada,
something like that type of thing.
A type of seaworld.
Seaworld is a day at the spa for animals
compared to marine land.
But yeah,
really?
Oh yeah,
it's that much worse.
Significantly worse.
So you worked for them.
Um,
you were released from your job fired as
it were.
I quit voluntarily.
I quit amidst a.
They say you're fired.
No,
no,
no.
Everybody admits her.
Quit.
I never gave him the opportunity to fire
me.
I made there were going to,
I think that that's the inclination I
had at the time.
But you were a trainer and you,
I think you opened up a lot of people's
eyes to it.
Um,
this was,
this was actually pre blackfish,
right?
This was pre blackfish.
You came on.
I,
I ate pot candy and uh,
was in Hawaii once,
like many years ago and I hadn't
experienced with dolphins were uh,
uh,
these dolphins were,
we were fishing in.
These dolphins were coming by the boat
and they were jumping and playing with
us and I remember thinking like this or
they might as well be people,
they might as well be like water people
or something.
These are,
there's something weird about this,
like they're,
they're enjoying playing with us.
Like as we yell to them,
they do more stuff.
Like they came by and they were jumping
and they were clearly looking at us when
they jumped to the water and I'd never
went to seaworld before because I had
seen some documentaries on dolphins and
I knew they were really smart and had
seen some documentaries and orcas as
well and it just always seemed really
fucked up to me that they make them stay
in these swimming pools.
But when you came on the podcast two
years ago and illuminated what it's like
behind the scenes,
at least that marine land,
it was horrific.
Man and I got a lot of tweets from
people,
um,
and facebook messages that said they
would never go to seaworld or marine
land again.
And then they realized really what it
was.
Then the documentary blackfish came out
and the whole world was sort of forced
to take a look at this and understand
that these animals are super intelligent
just because they can't manipulate
things just because they can't pick
things up and they can't write their
name.
They can't send you an email in their
environment that's unnecessary and
environment.
They're in the natural world.
They're moving through three d space and
the water,
they have free food and fish.
They have a huge community of fellow
orcas and fellow dolphins and they
communicate with each other through a
very complex language that we barely
understand.
They have a fucking language,
not like,
like monkeys go,
Ooh,
and the other monkey goes like kind of a
language.
Now they have a complex language with
dialects.
They might as well be water
people.
They've already evolved to be the top
Predator of the sea,
so there's no need for them to learn to
email.
They have no use for it,
so they've all their already the the
absolute top predators of the sea and
that's a way to look at it,
right?
Like we have this kind of view of
our position being the top.
Let mean we're kind of the top Predator,
but we're only the top Predator because
of our minds because we figured out how
to manipulate things.
They have huge minds,
they have incredible brains,
and then they're also.
They eat everything they want.
They don't need to evolve any further.
They've sort of mastered there
and they're amazingly adaptable.
They evolve in every which capacity to,
um,
to be able to,
to,
to adjust to the ever changing world
killer whales now,
uh,
I recently watched the documentary and a
on account of the melting ice in the
Arctic in the summer.
There's,
there's,
you know,
the,
the ice floes are receding,
they're becoming smaller and smaller
every year.
So now orchids are now going into
territories that they'd never had
before.
And you're in nun have documented that
they've seen orcas actually hunt bowl
whales,
which are 50 ton larger than an ORC
itself.
And what they do is they isolate the
animal.
They bite their,
uh,
their,
their fins,
they hold them underwater while another
oracle goes on top of their blow hole to
try to drown it.
I mean,
this is amazing.
Adapting.
Wow.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Well,
that's where they got their name killer
whales from killing whales.
Yeah,
exactly.
A lot of people think they're a type of
will there actually a cousin to a
dolphin.
That's right.
There are dolphins.
They're just the largest dolphin and the
Dolphin family,
they just,
they eat dolphins too,
which is kind of fucked up.
Killer whales,
humans eat monkeys unbenounced to most
killer whales are and you have to,
you have to sort of disassociate things.
You have to sort of draw a line between
killer whales being cute and loving and
just how you want to use the word
statistic.
They are,
they are evil,
evil,
evil in the way that they hunt and kill.
They are merciless,
you know,
well we have this idea of earth,
I'm like,
the smart things are supposed to be
compassionate and we're supposed to be
the stewards of the land and take care
of the little chipmunks and all the
other animals.
But because we're so far ahead of all
the other animals that we kinda.
That's how,
that's,
you know,
we kind of feel bad the way we treat
each other.
We want to kind of treat other animals
that way,
which is why,
you know,
animal rights organizations and all
these,
these people that really,
really love and care about animals.
That's where they sort come under fire
because they,
they want people to treat animals
different than animals.
Treat animals.
Animals are fucking mean shit to each
other.
And that's just the way of the world.
One of the videos that stood out for me,
and actually it was like a sort of a
wake up call for me was just how was,
how nasty nature is,
and it was a video that you actually
shared and it was of a bear taking down
a deer yard.
Yeah,
that guy's back.
Yeah.
I mean that's tough to watch,
right?
It is.
It was screaming.
The deer was screaming.
The bear was just eating it like
ferociously.
Well,
that's the thing about bears as opposed
to cats.
When a cat gets a deer,
they go right for the neck and they kill
it pretty quick because that's all they
do.
But bears do a lot of thing.
They eat berries and roots and plants,
so they don't always kill things.
That matter of fact,
they probably eat more plant matter then
they do animal matter.
So when they kill things,
they basically just hold these things
down and start eating.
It's a question of opportunity,
I guess,
if it arises.
Well,
eat a lot of funds.
That's a big issue in Canada where
you're from,
sir.
That's right.
They eat a lot of moose,
moose calves and a deer fonds they eat
them like as they're coming out,
they actually smell the placenta and
like the,
the,
you know,
all the stuff that surrounds the baby
and they'll find these moose as they're
giving birth and just literally pull
them right out of their body fucked up.
You know,
I'm an animal rights activist by a,
I suppose that's the label that I've
been given,
but I should mention that,
uh,
there are a lot of animal rights
activists that owe you a great deal of
credit for,
uh,
for your sort of,
your,
I want to use your sort of advocacy
despite the fact that there are,
there's a stark line between those who
believe in not killing animals and
everything else.
But then there are also other people
that can appreciate how nature operates.
Predator prey relationship and can also
appreciate that,
you know,
at least in what you've,
what you've said before,
you yourself are opposed to the
captivity of animals.
I mean,
the last time we were on,
you've mentioned of going to a zoo and
maybe eating a cookie and having a look
at the monkeys and being like,
you know,
you're throwing bose through animals
and,
and I very much respect the fact that
the way that you hunt in the way that
you eat is a kill what you eat,
movement or whatever you want to call
it.
And as an animal rights activist I can
say that that is a far more responsible
way than,
you know,
want to take a look at the factory
farming things and whatnot.
But,
um,
uh,
I forget.
Shit,
I forgot the point I was making.
Yeah,
I know what you're saying.
That it's sort of almost would seem like
I'd be a against them in some sort of a
way because I eat meat.
But the reality is a lot of animal
rights activists have fucking cats,
man.
And they feed their cats cat food.
And guess what?
That shit ain't grown on a cat food
tree.
You know,
there's,
there's a reality to the world.
And cats are brutal.
Cats are vicious little fuckers and they
need protein and if you have a cat and I
have two of them,
I love them.
They're awesome.
They come cuddle with me and while I'm
watching TV
on any given day,
I've got five cats,
three that I claim as my own too,
that just sort of come and go at will
wildcats.
Uh,
well.
One is one of the neighbors sort of,
I would say that he's sort of neglected
it.
And in terms of how you care for a
domestic cat.
Um,
and when he moved away he said,
look,
you know,
you,
you take care of this cat,
which I did.
I'm on my second level balcony.
I built this thing,
I call it the Taj mckinney.
It was this place where the cat could
come live in the winter.
Right?
And it's real cold.
And uh,
so he said,
you know,
do you want to keep this cat?
So I got it fixed and whatnot.
And he likes to show his gratitude by
bringing us a baby rabbits.
If you've ever seen a baby rabbit,
the cutest thing in the world.
And he maliciously licks them down to
the point of just chewing them until the
sound stops and leaving them as gifts.
And you can't help but love Eugene.
Eugene is the is amazing and loving cat.
He's also a just a cold blooded killer.
That's why they're alive.
We don't want to think about it that
way.
But animals today that are alive today
in 2016 are alive because their
ancestors,
especially predators,
like cats were fucking vicious.
They were vicious and ruthless and they
made sure they killed everything they
could because if you don't kill that
little baby rabbit,
the there might not be anything left for
you to eat that day and you might starve
or you might be too weak to get away
from something that wants to kill you.
Exactly.
He might be too weak to get away from a
bowl for you might be,
you know,
it's,
we,
we have a beautiful situation.
We'd go to the store,
we buy food that someone else killed for
us and we can get it every time.
It's not like a rare thing like you have
to wait for it if you have to put in a
lot of effort to get it throughout human
history.
It's always been difficult to acquire
food until recently.
Recently it's become so ridiculous.
You don't even have to get out of your
fucking car to eat.
You literally pull into a fucking drive
thru you hand these people paper within
seconds they hand you already cooked
meat in a sandwich,
a ground beef sandwich.
You put it on your seat,
they give you a glass of liquid sweet
shit.
He's stick that in your Little Cup
holder and you're eating.
That's insane.
Never before in human history is that
happened and that lack of effort and
lack of connection has bred a lot of
people that have a really distorted
understanding of life itself.
Love really distorted understanding of
what it takes to make a ground beef
sandwich.
You know,
if you want to raise a cow yourself and
go through that whole thing.
I have a few friends that do it.
I have my good friend Doug in Wisconsin.
He grows his own cows.
They're all grass fed and he,
he'll,
you know,
he gave me some,
some meat from it last time I was there
and he does it all himself.
He shoots him himself.
I mean he does the whole deed.
He butchers them,
he hangs them,
the whole deed and that guy understands
what it takes to make a ground beef
sandwich,
but most of us is pulling to that drive
through.
I think it's a privileged perspective.
It's people that have never had to do
anything like that.
Yeah.
Put any effort in raising their food.
I have friends that are farmers and it's
the same story and they love and respect
their animals through and through,
but at the end of the day,
they.
It becomes a steak.
It sounds like a contradiction,
right?
You know,
loving your animal,
put killing it.
I think in defense of anyone that likes
to call out hypocrisy is that you have
to take a look at the fact that there's
hypocrisy in absolutely everything you
do.
I mean the fact that loan that.
And I'm going to use vegans as an
example,
if you,
if you're going to look at what,
what an abomination of nature is really
the functions of society as a whole
city,
a city of physical city is an
abomination of nature.
Yeah.
So if you're a Vegan and you're,
for instance,
renting an apartment and driving a car
immediately,
there's hypocrisy in that.
And then this is not me calling out at
the idea of living a compassionate life
or propagating that.
I think that's fine.
I think it's great.
I encourage that.
I think the world needs more compassion,
but uh,
it's the judgment,
right?
It's the judgment.
I think,
uh,
when you,
when you start looking from the
perspective of someone who's privileged,
then yeah,
the judgment.
But I mean,
the judgment comes.
I think a lot of it comes from a real
place where people are like,
fuck this factory farming shit.
Fuck.
People who eat meat,
you know,
they get,
they get angry,
you know,
they love animals,
but it's so hilarious when you have a
cat that's feasting on a multitude of
animals that have been raised in
captivity.
All of them being the way they raise
animals.
When you you're buying
food,
man,
you're buying like
the worst treated animals ever.
I've never even heard of like ethically
source cat food.
I'm sure it exists.
I'm sure I haven't heard about it.
But even as it'd be sourced cat food,
whatever,
man,
it's murder.
If you feed your cats plants and there
are people who do that.
They have organ failure.
They fucking get heart attacks.
They die,
they can't live.
But there's a lot of people.
There's a whole.
I found these people because I found
these people because they're hating on
me after my last,
a comedy central special where I did
this bit about vegans.
So,
uh,
whenever people get really mad at me,
I like to go to their twitter page and
read what they're into.
It's like he's fucking people's twitter
page and I found out that there's a
whole Vegan cat forum,
Vegan cat owners and you know,
Hashtag cruelty free and these fuckers,
they,
they feed their cats plants and they
don't live long.
They die.
I'd like to have a conversation with
those cats.
I mean,
it would be nice if we could bridge that
language barrier.
Oh yeah.
If you rolled a mouse by one of those
cats,
they would dive on it like a,
like a dress,
like a man in the ocean that just
finally got to land.
Yeah.
Like if you just barely made it this
door,
that feeling that you get when you get
to land.
Oh,
I think there's,
there's,
there's a line,
there's a line in,
in all advocacy where how far are you
willing to go?
And it's a question of it really.
It's a question of how willing are you
to sacrifice.
I lived in South Korea for awhile and
this is a country that was leveled back
in the mid fifties.
They had to rebuild from essentially
nothing.
And so I saw a,
I mean I saw a pig heads being served up
on the side of roads,
but I can appreciate that these people
had suffered so much so that they had to
eat everything that was available to
them and I don't want to sit here and
defend that,
you know?
Okay.
So South Koreans are eating dogs and
whatnot.
And you know,
it's,
it's symbolic of their history and
whatnot,
but if you've got nothing left to eat,
I'd like to see how quickly your,
uh,
your ethics change,
right?
Because truly,
if you are truly suffering
and a dog,
I love dogs.
I have two dogs,
but let's be honest about what a dog is.
A dog is a little captive pet.
They're your buddies because you feed
them and you take care of them and you
have this relationship with them and you
have this agreement with them.
But if you ran into a wild dog,
there was a couple,
an elderly couple I want to say like
maybe seven or eight years ago that was
killed by a pack of wild dogs in
Georgia,
United States Atlanta.
Know that area.
Of course,
like what the fuck man?
Like dogs will fucking kill you if they
don't have any food.
If you,
if you think that they are like old
yeller or lassie or some know what they
are,
is exactly how you treat them from
birth.
If you get a puppy like my dog johnny,
I have a dog named Johnny cash.
He's the sweetest dog of all time.
He is so nice.
He's just so gentle.
He's just,
he's a mastiff and he's just so
friendly.
He just like anybody that comes over.
I never worried about him barking at
them or if he barks,
it's like,
hey man,
come play with me,
you know,
and when you go up to and be like,
what's up dude?
And he's always like super happy and
super sweet,
but it's because I've had them from the
time he was a baby.
And the guy who bred him,
um,
he,
he's always been like really ethical
about how he breeds these dogs and
they're very smart and kind.
But it's because of the relationship
that I had with him.
He knows I'm the Daddy.
I give him the food.
I give them the love,
you know,
it's all this,
this agreement as part of the
revolution.
I mean,
there
they're physically cute on account of
the fact that we selectively bred them
through and they themselves learned
that,
hey,
if I'm like really Das island cute,
look what these big puppy dogs,
I get more food and I get a better place
to live and get more of a warm,
a warm or shelter and I'm not likely to
wind up in the backyard and winter,
you know?
Well,
there was actually a radio lab podcast.
It was absolutely fascinating on raising
foxes and they raised foxes.
Yeah.
You say Fox is right.
It's not like dear.
I think so,
right?
I'm not going to correct you.
I'm goofy.
Seems like fishes foxes.
Fishes isn't acceptable word
if I'm not mistaken.
Yeah.
But you can use the word fishes.
Really.
I thought there was a large debate about
this and this was figured out back in
the mid nineties.
I started this as part of my.
You might be right.
I don't know.
Um,
but anyway,
the radio lab about foxes,
they selectively bred fox is based on
their behavior based on whether or not
they were aggressive in the ones that
were aggressive.
They killed and the ones that reacted a
certain way,
I don't remember the actual parameters
that they set,
but ultimately what it was,
and if you're into this google it
because I don't remember the name of the
episode,
but it was amazing.
Within a few generations,
like within less than 10 years,
they had completely changed with these
foxes looked like their ears had become
droopy.
Their jaws would become less pronounced
and smaller.
Their behavior was markedly different.
They were literally were almost a
different species and it was within 10
years.
Things adapt and change and that's the
reverse to that is,
and I think I heard on your podcast,
is that if you were to release a wild or
rather a pig and then it eventually
starts growing hair again and like maybe
protruding some tests because I'm out of
six weeks.
Yeah.
Within six weeks,
a fucking month of a pig living in the
wild and all of a sudden their hair
starts growing thicker and longer.
Their nose extends,
their tusks grow larger.
They become a different thing.
They literally start to.
They start to adapt to the,
the,
the physical shape of wild pig like,
have you ever been around wild pigs
here?
So not,
it's really interesting.
First of all,
they're all,
there are,
a lot of them are black.
They're like a dark,
dark color.
And I'm not even talking about boards
I'm talking about,
right.
Well,
we think of bore.
What is a board is actually the term for
a male pig.
Okay.
So when you see,
when people go to a menu and it says
wild boar sausage,
is it really?
How do you know?
It's not a wild girl,
you know,
it might be a sow like the word,
but it's a,
it's an ignorant terminology.
But then there's these Russian bores is
a different type of bore that lives in
other countries.
I don't know exactly what the genius is,
what the name is,
but the crazy thing is they're all
interchangeable.
There are other can all breed with each
other.
They're all the same thing.
Ultimately there's dodgy crossbred all
the time to sort of like pull out the,
uh,
the,
the advantages that we're looking for
when we're breeding them so you can make
a,
I know they were breeding I and I don't
know,
I can't remember where now,
but uh,
they were selectively breeding this
hunter have a dog and they just made
this mammoth machine but also a
domicile,
domicile and trusted creature.
So I wish,
I wish I remembered where I,
where I read that.
Yeah,
there,
um,
I mean it's,
it's amazing that dogs are a lot like
people in that way that there's a lot of
different variations of people.
No,
I mean you've got Shaquille o'neal and
then you've got a Natasha Leggiero,
right?
Little Tiny Natasha.
She's a comedian.
She's a 100 pounds,
but as you know,
there's people very almost as much as
dogs do in that sense.
You know,
we're,
we're all sorts of different shapes and
looks and.
But my point being wild animals,
like a feral cat.
I've had feral cats before.
I had a feral cat and he was fucking
nuts.
Did you actually get near him?
I could only me,
like literally only me,
no one else could get near and he would
hiss and fucking run away.
He would hiss at me half the time,
but if I approached them real slow,
but once I picked him up,
oh my God,
he would start preparing like crazy in
fact alone that you got close enough to
be able to pick them up as a pretty
rare.
Well,
what I did was I tamed him and it was a
weird way.
My friend Lanie,
um,
her boyfriend and her,
uh,
lived in this apartment and they had,
um,
down below I went to high school with
her and down below their apartment they
found a cat that had given birth to a
litter of wild.
And this is like Santa Monica.
So they're like,
oh my God,
what are we going to do?
So they decided to capture these cats
and try to get them home.
So me and like the asshole that I am.
I said,
all right,
I'll take it.
So I took one of them.
I brought them home and he was.
So I thought,
oh,
he's a kitten.
I'll bring them home and hang out with
my cat.
Everything will be cool.
And I had two cats at the time and he
was so fucking different than them.
He was like,
he'd look at you just fucking jump up.
Five,
six features mentally different.
Oh my God.
He was so scared of everything.
He was terrified.
It was.
Everything was a legitimate life or
death struggle.
So,
uh,
I did.
The Internet wasn't around back then,
so I was trying to figure out like,
okay,
how the fuck do I do this?
I got to get to know this little dude.
So yeah,
I food and what it did was I uh,
took this room in my house.
I put a bed in there.
It's like a guest room.
Sir had bad in there.
But uh,
I decided it's going to be my room now.
So a close myself in there,
put a litter box in there.
I brought some books and hung out with
his fucking cat for two days.
You're brave,
dude,
man.
This cat,
I think cat attack humans.
And it's a violent man.
He was a kitten.
It was a baby.
It was a baby,
I would have never done this with full
blown can.
You can,
you can't.
Full blown cat.
You just can't.
You can't train them.
He was only,
he was a little tiny thing.
So what I did was,
uh,
I would,
I would pet him and he per like crazy
and then when I put him down he will
hiss at me and run away.
Like he was so fucked up and I mean he
would jump.
He would say he fucked up my curtains,
jumped through the air and grabbed the
curtains and was like trying to climb
them and shit.
It was like out of control.
It's like,
dude,
I was just petting you a few seconds
ago,
but the life or death struggle that
these things were involved in even
whatever he got from his mom and his
dad,
like the genes that were passed down,
their genes have wild animals that were
really scared of everything and trying
to survive.
So he thought he was about to get eaten,
but it became my little buddy.
Yeah.
Took a while.
Was there an element of you that's sort
of loved the fact that it was bad ass
and scratching your curtains that shit
or you're like,
no,
I hate it.
It was fascinating.
It was like,
like I'm,
I'm a big fan of just the idea of
wildlife,
you know,
I think we live in cities and living in
cities and driving cars and sleeping and
nice houses and you know,
having a yard,
it's probably as close to a lot of
people get to nature on a daily basis.
They got a tree and some fucking grass
in the yard when you're out in wild and
you see wild nature.
One of the most fascinating things about
hunting is not just the pursuit of an
animal that you're going to eat,
but it's also spending a lot of time out
there in the real wild.
Like the real while we're fucking elk
lives,
you know,
we're a thousand pound animal lives its
life with fucking trees growing out of
his head and wanders through the forest
and couple weeks a month out of the year
gets to fuck.
And the rest of the time it's just
running from danger and eating,
fighting.
It's massively interesting.
Not the slightest clue.
Native of the modern world,
you know,
couldn't care less.
All it cares about is doing what it
naturally does to stay alive.
And that's really where animals should
be.
Yeah,
I mean,
that's the premise of,
uh,
of,
of what we're sort of dealing with that
it's just so fascinating when they're
there.
Um,
I encourage everybody.
I mean,
zoos are bullshit,
man.
They're bullshit.
They give you a stupid idea of what an
animal is.
It's just a business.
They're there to make your money.
They're not in reintroducing animals
into the wild there.
There's no program.
I mean,
I don't want to say there's nothing that
I'd like to hope that there are some
programs where they help animals and
then you know what it is.
It's like there's,
there's some animals that are so far
gone and needs so much help that it
actually,
it benefits them to have some of them in
captivity just so they can keep a
breeding population alive.
But ultimately,
does that breeding population get
reintroduced into wild in any capacity?
Some of them,
in some cases,
they've done it with tigers.
I know they've done it with some
animals.
It's hard.
You know,
it's fucking hard.
I mean,
I'm not.
I'm not sliding in any way.
People who care about wild animals.
I absolutely care about wild animals.
I think it's made people think you
don't.
If you're a hunter,
you eat and I get it.
I understand.
I understand where they're coming from,
but this is how I try to look at it.
Those animals are going to die no matter
what.
Every they're all going to die.
They're not going to live forever.
I'm not talking about wiping out
populations with hunting.
It's not.
I'm not doing that and I don't think any
hunters are trying to do that.
In fact,
what hunters are trying to do and what
they have done,
there's more deer in North America today
than they were when Columbus landed.
And the reason is a bunch of things,
but a big part of it is wildlife
management.
The wildlife agencies,
like department of fish and wildlife in
in America,
department of fish and game,
they're.
They're very careful about how many deer
they allow people to take and there's
consequences for poaching,
like stiff consequences.
They put you in jail and because of
these rules and enforcing these ethics,
they've allowed these animals to grow in
massive numbers and then of course
there's also agriculture.
Agriculture contributes to them a lot.
Like the most deer population or the
biggest deer population in America is
usually around people.
It's usually in people and farms.
Some of the biggest deer in the world,
like Iowa and Kansas,
they're known for like the biggest deer
in North America.
Canada is actually known for the biggest
ones,
but that has to do with cold
temperatures,
creating larger body to animals because
they have to generate more heat to stay
alive,
but my point is I'm not a hater of
animals exist just because I kill them
and eat them.
In fact,
I love them.
I really do.
It sounds.
I get it.
I know it sounds contradictory,
but what you're.
When you're eating an
animal is almost like a sacred thing.
When you hunt an animal and you kill and
you eat it,
it sounds like such a hippie horseshit
or some pseudo spiritual horseshit,
but it is kind of sacred.
There is something that happens when I
Cook a steak of an elk that I ate and I
grilled that thing and I eat it.
There's A.
There's a connection that I have to that
meat that's.
It's crazy.
It's an environment of different levels.
I don't know if the word earned.
It is the correct word for it.
I'm connected to it.
Sure.
You know,
I'm connected to that animal.
I'm connected to where this meat comes
from.
I know that that animal ate from the
grass,
you know,
in the forest,
and then I killed it and now I'm eating
it and this was like this weird,
crazy cycle,
but I grew up on a moose meat.
My Dad was a hunter,
avid hunter.
He went out there.
I mean a nice stock photo recently.
If a kid up on that microphone,
my friend,
so pull it towards you could pull it
towards the back.
I saw a photo recently have my dad back,
it has to be in the eighties and he took
down a bull moose.
I mean this was a massive animal and
the,
the best of my recollection was just
eating that animal.
So I mean even the fact alone that I'm a
meat eater and you know,
people rarely now back in 2012,
this is a different story,
but you know,
there's been a largely a paradigm shift
in how we view animals,
especially captive animals,
but that was called out quite a bit for
being a hypocrite.
Oh,
you eat meat or you got leather shoes
and it says as if my message is worth
nothing.
It's like,
well,
you're not paying attention to the,
to the core of my message,
like stop attacking the Messenger and
that's the sort of defense I have
against people who like to call
hypocrisy in everything.
Do you eat fast food and like store
bought food?
Yeah,
on my,
at my weakest moments and admittedly a
week,
man,
I tried,
I tried not to.
And last time I was on the show,
I had stressed that,
you know,
I,
I tried to get away from pork and still
I tried to make an ethical decision as
possible,
but not at three in the morning,
you know,
it just,
it happens.
It was just like last night we were
driving around with cruise around,
we needed to eat and we found our food
and we gave them that paper money and I
slept better.
So it's tricky,
right?
It's tricky trying to stay alive.
And the last time I was on the show,
I had actually mentioned that I was,
uh,
had a hard time getting off cheese.
And it's recent.
It's interesting because recently I read
a study that cheese may very well,
uh,
react to you or your mind may actually
react to cheese.
Similarly to crack that it was,
I wish I could quote it better again,
I'm not a scientist,
but I did read this article and it said
that the more processed that a food is,
that it creates some type of fat that
your brain itself becomes addicted to
it.
And they actually referenced an
addiction to crack.
And that it was similar.
Look at this.
Cheese really is cracks.
Jamie,
you're on the ball.
You need a raise change.
She's really,
it's crack steady reveals cheese is as
addictive as drugs.
That is fucking insane.
Well,
you know what that makes sense because
it tell you what Anthony Bourdain,
um,
that motherfucker loves cheese and he's
a,
had notorious substance abuse problems
in the past.
But I've fucking hung out with him,
man.
The way he talks about cheese is a way
young 22 year old guys talk about pussy
now you,
it's like,
oh my God,
stinky cheeses.
Stinkiest the better.
Pull that up so I can understand that.
Jamie,
let me,
let me pull it.
Pull it up so the techs could read.
This is fucking nuts.
For years you've been telling your
friends family cohort,
what is the title of this?
That it's from the La Times food daily
dish by Jenn Harris.
And uh,
it says for years you've been telling
your friends,
family,
coworkers,
and anyone who will listen to that.
You're addicted to cheese.
It's part of every meal or snack.
And you think about it constantly.
A few studies suggests that food
addiction is a real thing.
The study published by the US National
Library of Medicine examines why certain
foods are more addictive than others.
Researchers identified addictive foods
from about 500 people who completed in
the Yale Food Addiction scale,
Huh?
Okay.
It's p achieves happens to be specially
addicted because of an ingredient called
caisson.
Okay.
It's a protein found in all milk
products during digestion case.
Am I saying that right?
Case in C,
a s e I n releases opiates.
Whoa.
Called casomorphins.
Holy Shit.
Opiates get released when you eat
cheese.
Really play with the dopamine receptors
and trigger that addictive element.
Wow,
that's amazing.
People are gonna.
Start putting some crafts.
Synthetic cheese and syringes.
I don't know what I've been eating
lately.
I've been eating raw cheese,
beginning raw cheese from the whole
foods.
Whole foods has the raw cheese which
made with raw milk.
It's fucking great.
It's really good.
Raw milk is great too.
That's the thing I've gotten away from
the most.
I growing up,
I drank a lot of milk,
a lot of milk.
I would say more than the average
person.
Now I can't,
I can't stomach it.
Burleson milk.
Yeah.
I just can't.
I have no urge for it whatsoever.
Now just so how do you eat cookies?
Okay.
There's the window.
Hypocrisy comes in,
right?
The largest hypocrite I admitted.
Yeah,
so you're right.
So I guess I do have,
I do have a different course.
I,
and I,
I've heard on the podcast before and I'm
going to accept some of the judgment
that's going to come from it,
but I've made the switch to almond milk
and feel free to rant about how bad
almond milk is for a,
a,
the environment a for all the almonds
that are being wasted and the water use
and everything else.
I mean there is a perspective that
people like to say,
Oh,
almond milk,
that's a healthy alternative.
But if you look at it from the other
side,
the environmental impact,
everything else,
almond milk shit.
So.
Well it's not bad.
It's just what almond milk.
Here's one thing that everybody needs to
consider when you buy almond milk and it
tastes good.
It's like,
oh,
this is so sweet.
Look at the fucking label bitches.
All right,
because guarantee that shit is filled
with sugar.
Duncan called me up,
dude,
I've been drinking almond milk.
It's amazing.
It's so delicious.
I go,
okay,
what?
What?
What kind of drink?
And he tells me that I go look at the
label and look how much sugar is in it.
He goes,
Holy Shit.
He's like 18 grams.
I'm like,
yeah,
every class is 18 grams of sugar.
All right.
That's a whole lot of sugar.
I think you're not supposed to have like
if you're trying to be healthy,
I don't believe you're supposed to have
more than 25 grams of a day.
I think there's like a limit where you
hit a limit and if you go over that
you're like,
Whoa,
you're fucking with your body there and
this dude's getting most of that from a
glass of supposedly healthy almond milk.
Well,
I don't drink a lot of it admittedly,
but tastes the alternative.
Yeah,
I think it does taste good.
That's kind of nutty flavor.
It's got a nice texture.
What can I say?
It's,
I'm really bad when you're in a place
like California,
which is normally how experiencing a
drought today.
It's porn like fucking crazy.
We're in the middle of the Nina.
I around know if you'll know theses Nino
and it's a fix.
Do you want to warm the water?
You'll think they do.
There's no consequences to your actions.
Danielle is ia.
It couldn't wait three days for me to
go.
No,
it's good.
It's good.
I like it.
I like watching all these fucking
dummies who have no idea how to drive
when it rains out.
Oh,
that's one of the things I loved about
when I lived in Colorado for the brief
time when it would snow.
It's like,
ah,
yes.
I love a little consequences for living
on earth and nature is a thing that we
avoid in California.
We have avoided it.
It's doesn't.
It barely exists.
When we go to the ocean.
I'm like,
Whoa,
cool.
Nurture.
That's the only time you know you can go
visit it.
You can go to the park and visit it,
but it doesn't rain.
There's no.
Whether it's no consequences.
I feel like water probably in California
as some,
in a way,
the glue that's going to keep the ground
together because you guys are bad ass
drought.
I've seen these before and after
pictures and I'm like,
wow.
And I remember when I was repeatedly
asking you to come back in the show,
I'd be like,
I got to get down there before
California runs out of water.
We're not out a water.
We're right next to the fucking ocean.
They just need to figure out a suck that
water out of the ocean.
Get the salt out of it.
It's it.
Look what if we could put people on the
moon,
how the hell can we not get salt out of
the fucking water?
It's to just stop making smaller phones.
Stop adding new TV channels to DIRECTV.
Figure it out.
You fucks.
Just get in there and suck that water
out and let's turn this bitch knew a
rain forest.
Starts praying that shift from the sky
hollows chem trail,
planes and all these Wackos or worried
about,
let's have those fuckers for real.
Just fill them up with water and just
dump it on us.
Just get those giant planes filled with
water and just dump water and everybody,
surely a million dollar idea.
Uh,
I think it probably costs a little more
than that,
but I was thinking of the earnings if
you can manage to figure out how to,
how to extract that.
So they actually have,
um,
a desalination plant that they are going
online with this year,
I believe in San Diego.
Is that this year?
Do you know that story?
Jamie?
Um,
there was a,
uh,
there apparently they do have emerging
technologies to extract salt from water
and they've used them in the Middle East
where they just have ungodly amounts of
money.
You know,
they just have so much money over there
because of the oil that some of these,
some of these dudes have,
uh,
tried to use that money to create
machines that can suck the salt out of
the water and figure out some way to
filter it.
Bill Gates can drink water from his own
shit.
You'd like to think that someone could
do what he's doing.
What he did,
he'd been invented a machine that we
extracted water from human shit.
And then he was like,
from actual shit from like think it was,
I think it was shit,
we'll use the word sewage just for the
sake of making a little more broader
spectrum of.
Well that's what you do when you have
$90,000,000,000 bold.
Everybody's getting Fiji and heavy on.
And I heard Fiji's not even really from
Fiji.
Those fucks I heard.
That's bullshit.
Yeah.
I heard Fiji is just some fucking.
Just some spring water from the middle
of nowhere.
Plant opened up December 14th.
Oh,
did open up.
Okay.
So went online at the end of 2015.
That's interesting.
It's good.
Huge developments.
That's gonna happen.
That's gonna.
Fix the whole fucking problem.
We're going to go Jesus Christ.
Why we were right next to so much water.
You have to fly over it in a fucking
plane and it takes 16 hours to get to
the other side.
And I'm just going to.
And I'm going to plead ignorant here,
but why are we not just showering with
saltwater,
maybe extinguishing fires with
saltwater.
Why are we not using the salt water in
different capacities that we're not
imposing so much?
Good question to,
to,
to process it.
Um,
uh,
the thing about saltwater is it does
corrode things like really badly if
you're near the ocean.
Uh,
I have a friend who has a beach house
and every time we go to hang out with
them and his beach house,
like everything's like all fucked up and
corroded.
Like they're constantly dealing with
corrosion because of the salt in the
air.
It's just a constant moisture and salt
together.
They corrode the shit out of things.
That's why I'm.
Why used to live in Boston?
The uh,
cars are always fucked up like old cars.
It's hard to find like if you want to
find like a 1970 plymouth or something
like that,
it's hard to find one that's in good
shape because they're all rusted out
from the salt that they throw in the
ground when it,
when it snows out to melt the snow.
So that's why my cars were all fucked
up.
Right.
So the point being almond milk,
the problem with almond milk,
because it uses a lot of water,
they use a shitload of almonds.
I guess you're extracting very little of
the,
of the nutritional value from the
almonds per capita if you will,
like versus like this mass amount.
Right?
But writing it down or what?
That's what I say,
dude,
fuck them.
Okay.
So I'll eat almost all day.
Not Care about their life.
That's the thing about life.
We don't really.
We don't really care much about plant
life.
We want it to be there,
but we don't think about it the way we
think about animal life.
Like we want animal life to be there,
but we don't want anybody to kill it.
Like plant life.
The only time people get bummed out
about plants and someone chops down
ancient redwood or something like that.
Like,
Oh God,
how could you.
And again,
I've read somewhere where plants can
actually hear when they're being eaten
and I've seen some studies,
or rather I read something somewhere
again,
where a plant has a similar hunting
behavior as animals,
where they're actually the roots will
physically chase or get fined their
nutrients.
So,
you know,
some would argue that,
uh,
that plants are just as conscious or
conceivably conscious as a,
as animals as well.
Well,
they're different in the same way that
humans are different than dolphins.
We were talking about the intelligence
level of an Orca versus the intelligence
level of a person.
Like we would like to think that we're
smarter
than them,
but there's no evidence of that.
If we lived in the ocean,
we would look like fucking idiots if we
were swimming around with them trying to
stay alive,
they'd be like,
look at these dummies with their fingers
and they're exposed.
Dick's,
he's going to eat by crabs.
These fucks,
they can't even sleep in the water.
Like what are they going to die?
They would think we were retarded.
Right?
So that's sort of how you know when we
look at their life and what they're
doing,
like they're perfectly adapted to their
environment.
Well,
a tree is perfectly adapted to it's
environment and there's been a lot of
research done on plant intelligence and
there is a lot of evidence to suggest
that these aren't inanimate objects like
a rock.
It just happens to get larger every
year.
No,
these are living things.
They're living things that do
calculations that somehow or another
communicate with each other.
They let other plants know when they're
being preyed upon.
They develop methods in order to
discourage predation and that's where
poisonous plants come from.
All poisons.
Plants come from discouraging predation.
That's what.
That's what it's all about.
It's funny because one of the cruelest
things I've ever watched,
and maybe it's because I have a vivid
imagination,
but if you've ever seen a venus fly
trap,
it's like slowly dissolve.
You know its prey.
It's like wild shit.
Pretty evil.
Yeah.
Well there's one that aedes rats,
there's a fucking plan.
The Amazon that looks like a giant tulip
that each route.
Pull that up,
Jamie.
A rat eating plant and it's,
it's a plant,
it's like it has like a sickly sweet
smell to it apparently,
and these animals go in it looking for
food and they go and just close in on
them and they don't fight and kill them.
They slowly enveloping,
just smush them,
just trap them,
smash them,
and then absorb their nutrients,
break them down to the very molecules
and protein and liquids are going to get
250 people would sign out of plants.
Doorstep,
protest them.
Well,
plants are alive,
man.
We need to eat living things.
Life eats life live feeds on life that
it just does.
And what's going on now with animal
rights,
activism and pita and the Animal
Liberation Organization is people who
care.
That's what really is.
Whether they're misguided,
whether I agree with him.
There are people who care and there are
people who feel deeply about these
animals.
Check this motherfucker out.
Watch this shit.
That's hunting behavior for sure.
Look at this case will be fishing.
What happened?
We went,
here we go,
here we go.
So this thing,
um,
it,
it has like this open leaf.
And these plants,
what are we watching here?
This is like a fast speed up version of
it.
So what happens is,
um,
is it growing here?
Is that we're watching.
I thought final countdown
was about to play it that way too quick.
It was just a mouse falling into a
plant.
So I didn't want to go with that.
And this one was a guy in front of one,
but this is,
um,
we're watching the whole fucker grow.
This isn't.
So this is what happens.
This is,
this is where it is.
It opens up and it looks like almost
like a hamper.
We throwing a closing or something or
strange green vagina.
And that looks like a snake.
Like that's crazy.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of that in the animal
world.
Um,
this is all just growth though.
We're watching like high speed rail.
We're not gonna watch it,
eat anything.
Jamie.
We're going to have to find another
video.
When these things open up,
they open up and the rats are attracted
to the smell and they climb in that tube
and when they climb in that tube,
they wind up dying.
Show the one that,
uh,
that has a hair goes eatsa fraud.
Here.
Go.
This is perfect.
This is the one that's just going to
close right up on it.
It already did.
Jamie.
Just watched this.
Just do it from the beginning.
Here it goes.
Watch this.
He's just hanging out.
Like,
what's that smell?
Let me just blew up and that it eats
him.
It's over.
Yeah,
it eats a.
and this is a new plant.
They've only discovered this fucker I
think like five or six years ago.
And um,
eat frogs,
all sorts of things.
Look at this.
Watch this because this Venus flytrap.
Wow.
That's a wrap.
Bitch.
That's cold blooded.
That is so fucked up.
Play that again.
Could God that fucking frog.
Okay.
He's like,
what's the smell?
So I bought.
That is so crazy.
I said it's one of the.
For me anyways.
That's one of the toughest things to
watch.
I think it's ours.
That poor animals are going to be just
laying there a incapacitated until
ultimately wow.
If it's suffocated than it is what it
is.
No.
A Venus flytrap could do that.
I didn't know the Ada frog.
Is that a different plant or is that a
Venus flytrap?
It looks like the fingers.
It's just.
I know that's what those plants have
figured out is their method to get
ahead.
That's their hustle.
There.
Hustle is they trap things and they suck
them into their body and they eat them.
They survived.
They evolve and get bigger.
Get stronger.
Yeah.
Those are predators,
man.
These are carnivores.
So look at these.
Look at these fucking hands getting
killed by this plant.
Oh my God.
There's so many of them,
man.
There's so many different.
Weird one.
Look at this.
They roll up these ants.
Oh,
this is so creepy.
It looks like a giant green tongue with
like weird sort of spikes that grow on
it and the spikes lift up and wrap
around the aunt or the fly here in this
case and just trap them and once they
have them trapped in there and he's
stuck in the stickiness of the.
Look at this with these ants and then it
wraps up and rolls them up like a
Burrito.
That's fucked up,
man.
That was a tough place here.
It doesn't give a fuck,
but I think nature is beautiful.
I think it's amazing.
I think if you really want to see nature
of the weight of see it is obviously
documentaries and dvds if you want to
stay in home,
but
to actually see the physical animal go
somewhere,
go somewhere and see them,
go see them in their natural
environment.
That's what you're going to get a real
respect for them.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I'm taking one of my upcoming trips this
year.
I want to take my kids with me.
I'm not when I kill an animal because I
don't want to make any noise.
I don't want to have to quiet them down
because it's a very patient thing and
it's something that will be very hard
for a five year old to do.
Would you take issue with them seeing
the kill itself?
No.
They've watched it on TV.
They've seen the meat,
they've seen me butcher meat.
They haven't seen me kill the whole
animal,
but they've seen me chop up a giant elk
backstrap and turn it into steaks in the
middle of the kitchen just sitting there
with a cutting board,
slicing it up and they ask questions and
there's a disconnect between that meet
having been a live animal.
No,
no standing.
Well,
they've seen me on television kill
animals on a TV show.
Okay.
So they know that I do it.
They know that I have targets in the
yard and I'm always practicing arrows
and archery.
But um,
I want what I want to do is not,
not even the hunting aspect of it.
I want to take them so they could see
the elk when elk are running and they're
screaming is amazing.
It's like you're in Jurassic Park.
It's like you run some hobbit movie or
something when you're in the hills.
Like,
um,
what I want to do is I'm going to,
I want to plan a week of hunting and
then I want to pay a guide just to call
in the elk so we could just watch them
because I just want the kids to see what
it's like when you make this noise and
then you see this fucking thing looks
like a giant forest horse that comes up
and wants to fuck.
And they're screaming.
They have this crazy whale.
It's,
it's amazing to watch outside of
hunting,
like separate that,
that's,
that's all great and everything,
but just be just being a part of the
environment,
like stepping on the ground where these
things live wild and they all they're
worried about.
It's like mountain lions and bears and
that's what they're doing.
They're trying to stay alive.
They're trying to get laid and they're,
they're existing in this very bizarre
world that we rarely get to see that we
can't really truly appreciate it because
we don't have to worry about it.
We don't have to worry about what their
concerns are anymore.
We even like,
look at Africa,
man.
They have these tourism things they do
in Africa,
but a good percentage of them are in
these high fence operations where
they've sort of fenced in these animals
and these giant contained wildlife
sanctuaries and the animals thrive in
there.
But how do you see,
you mean the way you see him as he get
in a jeep and you drive around and even
if it's something,
there's something fucked up about
knowing that they're not,
they can't leave even if it's like 10
miles in every direction,
there's a fence and they would never
Rome 10 miles in the wild.
The fact that there's a fence at all,
the fact that we've gotten are greasy
little hands or in their world,
it kinda changes it in a way.
Well,
it's funny because I actually a running
deer,
a male of course,
uh,
trying to enter the premises of marine
land and there's a large fence around it
and this thing was.
So.
I mean,
uh,
running deere is actually a pretty
dangerous animal.
I mean,
they are,
they are there.
Their sexual urges are far beyond any
type of.
Like it just trumps any behavior that
they would have.
So this thing was smashing,
it must've been smelling the females
inside the park,
but it was repeatedly smashing itself
against the fence trying to get in to
the point where he'd ripped half its
face off,
its antlers were getting fucked up.
So we actually called a hunter who had
been in the back like,
who had had the,
the permission by the owner of Greenland
to hunt inside some wild deer.
And we went and got him and he came,
put the first boat directly through the
animal,
didn't kill it,
got a second bowl and then uh,
took,
uh,
put the animal down and won't kill it.
And then we had to sausage some,
some time later.
Of course.
Yeah,
they get crazy.
Moose are super aggressive when they get
horny,
they're dangerous.
I've been in Algonquin Park at the times
when,
uh,
when uh,
the Moose are running.
And that is by far the most dangerous
animal out there for you.
I mean,
you don't want to get anywhere near a
running moocs.
They're so big.
Have you ever seen one in the wild?
I have,
yeah,
of course.
The first time I saw one out in the wild
was in the middle of British Columbia in
the forest and it was like the first one
I saw it was a female and we saw them in
the distance and I was like,
oh my.
It was like that scene in Jurassic Park
where Jeff Goldbloom lifts his head up
out of the jeep and it's like,
what?
Like,
you can't believe how big they are.
They're like the males get to 1800
pounds,
1800 pounds.
Like the biggest elk that I killed was
around a thousand pounds.
So imagine something fucking twice the
size of that.
Drive your car.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
Well my friend,
my friend Mike Hawk Ridge who runs a big
country outfitters up there,
he got chased by a female Moose on a
horse.
He was on his horse and the female had
the caps with them,
which is when they get really fucking
dangerous and they get aggressive and
the horse was running in the fucking
moose was gaining on them and he was
like,
Holy Shit.
And he realized like,
Oh my God,
like this is fucking,
this could be good to the horse.
Kept his cool or kept it its footing at
least that have fucked up scene.
Oh yeah.
Well if the horse slipped and fell or if
the horse said,
fuck this guy on my back like I'm out.
I don't think he could.
I mean he had a saddle and everything
like that.
I don't know if the horse was that smart
point to what we're saying is a almond
milk is bullshit.
That's,
that's the bottom line.
Almond milks sucks.
It's all right.
So,
um,
what has changed since the two years
that you've been here?
Other than there's a lot of public
acknowledgement and understanding now
that wasn't available or wasn't.
It sort of wasn't at the level that it
is now.
I think people are much more outraged
now about seaworld and about a marine
land and just the idea of captive orcas
and dolphins.
And in your case walruses well.
So the first thing we did was we managed
to ban a orchid captivity in Ontario.
That's,
that's done now.
So marine land will never.
And Mark my word,
they will never acquire another,
a killer whale,
whether it be a wild caught or not.
So that was a big win for animal
activists,
if you will,
or anyone for that matter has invested
interest in the wellbeing of animals
just as of January first 2016.
Now,
uh,
there are standards of care,
which is what I actually petitioned the
government for back in 2012 because when
I came out and sort of revealed marine
land for what it actually is behind the
scenes,
uh,
during that time,
there were no standards of care.
You could literally have dug a hole in
your backyard,
fill it with whatever you want and then,
you know,
plunk yourself some dolphins in there.
And that was fine.
There were no standards of care.
There was no,
uh,
oversight in any capacity.
That's changed.
I'll be at the letter of the regulations
that we have now.
I would say that few people are really
satisfied.
There's still lots of work to do with
them,
but the fact alone that they are now
legislated,
we'll be able to,
uh,
to change some of the,
the,
the parameters,
you know,
the one of the biggest things that
there's in fact water quality
parameters.
Uh,
when I,
in the last eight months of my tenure at
marine land,
I was witnessed to,
um,
some of the more horrific things that a,
that caustic water can do to animals.
Uh,
I witnessed dolphins lose their skin.
I mean the skin was flaking off,
literally flaking off their skin and
we're not talking about it.
Just a regular slough.
Uh,
there was some permanent idemage that
was done.
What happened was there was,
there was a breakdown in a disinfection
unit,
a water disinfection unit.
We used to use ozone in conjunction with
chlorine.
Ozone mitigated the use of chlorine,
so he didn't have to use so much of it.
And when that machine broke down,
the resolve was just keep pumping more
chlorine and keep pumping more clearance
flirting.
And because we were in the off season,
the public wasn't seeing this.
Okay.
And this is 2012.
I had an old shitty blackberry,
but I knew I was conscious enough of how
bad things were that I started snapping
photos,
taking videos and you know,
there was a major complacency for
management because hey shit,
we're not opening again for another
eight months or six months,
whatever it be.
I think the issue started in October.
They opened in November and so there
were no parameters.
There was no oversight.
There was nowhere for me to run to find
help.
Now there is that.
So now marina has to adhere to new
legislation that will require some
capital investment from them,
which of course is something that we'd
like to hear,
um,
but there's at least some stuff in
place.
And most importantly is most recently
there's a senator,
a federal Canadian senator,
a liberal senator by the name of,
of uh,
Willie Moore is what we're actually the
Hashtag.
We're saying free willy more and sort of
a in the hopes of getting Justin
Trudeau's attention.
And he's introduced the bill.
It's called the ending of captivity of
whales and Dolphins Act.
It's a bill,
a two.
Oh,
three,
I believe,
and uh,
this bill,
once it passed the Senate and ultimately
passes into law,
is going to ban both the import,
the breeding of all whales,
porpoises captivity or rather,
and whales in captivity in Canada.
Basically putting a shelf life on marine
land in the capacity that they,
that they do business.
Now,
this is a bill that I'm urging people.
Look if you,
if you give a shit about animals in
captivity,
you know,
a tweet,
Justin Trudeau are our recently elected
prime minister.
And uh,
yeah,
we're,
we're really trying to,
we're looking forward to moving this
thing forward.
Beyond that,
it's always a,
it's always a thing about the,
the what I call the paradigm shift.
Um,
people don't want to see the only visit
zoos,
no more attendance at marina is a
nihilistic.
Now this doesn't stop him from exacting
a gross revenge on me,
but nonetheless,
we're still afloat.
We're still here three years later
amidst all these bullshit lawsuits as I
stressed before,
these slapp lawsuits,
strategic lawsuit against public
participation when I got sued,
well had hope to one day we'd be in
court.
Here we are well over a thousand days
later and not,
and I've spent,
well I say I've spent,
but we've publicly raised a lot of
money.
We spent collectively over the three
former animals trainers that are turned
whistleblowers.
We've collectively spent over $100,000
and not had a single day in court.
So it's all just trying to drain you
legally.
Joe.
The fact alone that I'm speaking into
this microphone is exactly what Marine
Lynn doesn't want.
I'm dangerous to the anti captivity or
rather the captivity industry because I
know a lot of things.
Of course seaworld was if you want to
use the term in bed with marine land,
a seaworld likes to acquire because
because in the states you can't acquire
a wild caught animals at seaworld would
do is they would get the animals that
marine land would import.
So marina would import wild cod belugas
from Russia breed them,
and because the calves were bred in
captivity,
they could now be moved to the states.
So this was how seaworld in the states
was trying to continue to acquire these
animals.
So that's,
and this is exactly what this bill is
sort of trying to stop,
so that's one of the things that sea
world was full of shit about because
seaworld was trying to say we haven't
done like one of one of their
commercials was saying that they
haven't,
they haven't caught in a whale in 35
years.
Yeah.
They haven't captured a whale from the
wild in 35 years.
There's a number of examples of that
being bullshit.
One being a wild orca or what they
deemed rescued,
orca named Morgan that was captured off
the coast of the Netherlands who was,
you know,
it was by itself.
It had left it's potter,
it was,
it had lost contact with his pod.
And so it's a,
it's a,
a dolphinarium called Darfur,
dolphinarium hi bike.
They acquired this animal and then what
they did or they took it and they called
it rehabbing and then they,
of course demon non releasable.
They sent it to a place and it's
outlined in a black blackfish.
In fact because there's a,
there's a large,
uh,
the documentary blackfish.
There's a relationship between seaworld
and,
uh,
a facility called in tenor reef.
It's called Laurel parking.
So what seaworld did was they had that
animal Morgan,
the wild Orca,
transferred to,
um,
to Laurel Park and now
it's actually part enlisted as part of
its collection.
That's a wild caught animals.
So seaworld was sit there and tell this
idea that we haven't done this in years
and yet they're,
they're importing wild,
wild caught animals that have just
recently bred one the babies from Canada
and then they're,
they're basically adding to their,
to their stock of animals.
This other wild caught animals.
So we can talk about the bullshit that
seaworld spews all day.
But the nice thing is most people are
now conscious of it.
Most people look at it and say,
I mean every time seaworld tweets,
anything,
they get a lot of fucking hate because
people know now they know they're
essentially a slavery organization.
Yeah.
I can't disagree.
And saying that we haven't captured a
slave in 35 years,
it's still disgusting.
The idea that that's how that's okay,
that they can just say,
we haven't participated in slavery
catching slaves in 35 years.
We just keep them here.
Locked in a tiny little.
Have you ever seen the map?
I'm sure you have.
The parking lot is in juxtaposition to
the actual area where the dolphins give
to swim.
The most heartbreaking one is would that
pool is right next to the ocean when you
could see it physically right there.
There's a lot of facilities with the
dolphins or spy hopping and they can see
the.
See it's right there.
The ocean is right there.
It's a question of picking them up and
throwing them back in there.
Why can't they make it so that they can
go back and forth?
have like set up a facility?
This is the way you can make it.
Some of these animals can transition
back into the wild and that if they do
decide to come and participate in show
that they could do it on their own.
Free will have like an open area where
it's connected to like a dock where the
pools and the areas where the animals
swim,
they should be examined by some marine
biologists.
That demon ethical,
this is an enormous place as long as you
don't keep them in here,
but they can do their stuff in here and
everything will be fine and have it be
actual ocean water and then have an open
portal so you don't have to worry about
them starving to death in a wild.
They can always come in and get food
anytime they want and that way you can
kind of keep both things happening like
they develop a relationship with these
animals where it's a.
it's an actual real relationship.
It's not captivity.
They come because they want to get food
sorta like squirrels,
the park or something.
This is exactly what animal rights
people if you will,
and and scientists these days are
advocating for.
They want seaside sanctuaries where
which these animals remain in human care
and are available for people to watch.
Of course you're going to have to keep
the stop.
The breeding,
the breeding has got to stop.
Ultimately,
you want to phrase this this out
completely,
unless they want to fuck on their own in
front of everybody,
I'm going to guess that people are,
that the scientists going to try to stop
that,
but that's what people are advocating
for really is the seaside sanctuaries.
But seaworld keeps saying that,
oh,
there's so many pathogens in the water
and it's going to make these animals to
central.
Again,
it's all bullshit.
You just mean.
Well,
it means they think that they're going
to become susceptible and say,
or that or that.
The transition itself from captivity
into this new environment is going to be
too much to stomach.
Well,
where was that logic when they were
plucking them out of the,
out of the ocean and putting them in
these concrete tanks?
Right?
Well,
they're going to have to adapt if,
if they changed the laws and they make
it so that,
that's,
um,
that's just the only acceptable
solution.
Then they'll adapt.
There wasn't any way.
There was a law,
uh,
introduce a couple of years ago by his
name was assemblyman Richard Bloom.
And it was a bill that ultimately was
going to retire all the orcas in San
Diego to seaside sanctuaries.
The issue that was raised is that there
are no seaside sanctuaries yet.
And so the bill ultimately died.
Well,
fucking seaworld use your money,
bitch.
What?
Yeah.
You have a giant facility.
You obviously made money off of those
things.
What,
how down are they right now?
Yeah.
Well their net worth or rather their,
their company valuation when they did
their initial IPO,
initial public offering was uh,
in and around $2,000,000,000.
And basically that's down to one point.
It was down to one point five at one
point seven.
So,
you know,
animal activism,
if you will,
has really caused them a lot of harm
financially.
They've literally taken,
I'm just aware that they're not,
they're not.
Well of course they're still worth a lot
of money.
But for a slave organization to be worth
over a billion dollars,
that's kind of fucked.
And then you could buy stock in the
slave organization.
Yeah.
What the fuck man,
I watched that stock price daily.
I mean,
they're not recovering that man.
Are they?
Have they rebounded?
Is that wasn't showing depending on
where they're at today because of us.
Well,
look it,
look at yesterday.
Look,
people don't like me.
Fuck a reuben.
I'm going to get a lot of that to pump
your money in the seaworld,
the others and investment.
Yeah.
Well it's not going to be around in 20
or 30 years,
so you're right.
It's more,
the more we do research into the
language of these things to the more
scientists.
I mean they've been trying to,
you know,
John Lilly was trying to get them to
speak human.
He was trying to get them to speak human
languages like way back in,
I guess it was like the sixties.
Yeah.
And he even set up an experiment where a
woman lived in sort of this bizarre home
where there was water.
She spent most of her time,
like waist deep in water.
Yeah.
Which wasn't jagging off the dolphin.
That was the problem.
She checked off the Dolphin Dolphins get
horny.
And she was like,
well,
this is a distraction.
Let me just check them off real quick.
And,
and everybody's like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck did you just say?
And that's really,
we've come a long way since then because
clearly that was just a question of the
animal mimicking.
I mean,
the idea that this animal's going to
adopt the English language over and
above.
Yeah.
But,
but to be fair,
the mimicry itself was pretty
impressive,
pretty impressive.
And I've worked with dolphins and I
never,
I never actually tried to have the
dolphin mimic my own sound,
but with what I was watching that duck,
I watched a documentary recently as well
is uh,
it was pretty impressive.
It's pretty impressive.
Very.
But the idea that that was teaching or
trying to bridge the communication was
pretty.
I mean,
that's,
that's out there.
Well,
it was all lily could come up with back
then.
At the time,
first of all,
he was on acid almost every day.
I mean,
lily was a fucking maniac.
You take ketamine and he was the guy
that invented the isolation tank,
which is one of my favorite things in
the world.
I have yet to do it.
I can't wait to though.
I'm going to.
How long you here for?
I'm here till uh,
I leave Friday morning.
Like hell yeah.
I love that.
Will set it.
Set you up with the end of the float
lab.
There's a new place in Pasadena and that
just opened up the largest place in the
world.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
Yeah,
we'll look it up.
That's fantastic.
Appreciate that.
What part of town he's staying in while
you're here?
We're going to be in Venice beach.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's where the float lab is.
Oh,
how about that dude?
That's perfect.
That we're going to call them right
after this.
We'll set it up.
I'm extending because crash is the best
car.
I've heard that.
He's been on the podcast before.
He's a fucking maniac.
I love him.
And he kept the float business alive
with innovation back when no one did.
Um,
I had a guy who was fixing my tank and
um,
you know,
I had an old tank which is one of the
original tanks and it was starting to
deteriorate a little bit because I'd had
it for awhile.
And um,
this guy told me,
it was like,
this is crazy guy in Venice.
It's making these tanks.
It's just,
they're just so much better than anybody
else's pods.
Is it?
Or like full square rooms?
I mean get into it.
It looks like a small meat locker.
That's what it looks like.
You open a door and you climb and he has
a bunch of different models.
You have some that you gotta gotta gotTa
Kinda Bend over when you get in.
But mine is like seven feet tall and
like nine feet long.
It's huge.
I've heard you say that you find it like
incredibly therapeutic and just clear
your mind,
take you to places where you can think
clearly.
I could benefit from some of them.
It's great for that.
It's great physically for your body to.
I'm like my back,
like opens up and relax.
I feel like I couldn't like pop.
It just felt like stretching my,
my,
my shoulders up.
It just goes pop,
pop,
pop.
Because everything's just relaxing.
It's a great source of magnesium because
there's a thousand pounds of epsom salts
in the water.
My older one was like 800 pounds,
but the bigger one requires more so it's
a thousand pounds of salt and that epsom
salt,
when you're bodies floating in that
your,
your skin is absorbing the magnesium
super healthy for you.
He used to feel great.
You get out of there,
you feel great and be going like I do
trip your balls off in there.
I went on mushrooms on New Year's Eve,
took mushrooms,
so I was cleaning my office and I'm
like,
look what I got here,
do I do this?
So I ate the mushrooms and then I didn't
take a big dose,
but I took enough where I started
getting really weird.
I waited about an hour until I couldn't
take it anymore.
I was like,
I can't be around people anymore.
I got to get in the tank.
And then I got in the tank and the tank
was good to you for bracing.
Just to set me on a voyage.
Just sent me an,
a voyage through my mind and got me in
this very positive groove.
Do you really like it was,
it was a good trip because it was,
um,
it was a new years eve trip.
It was like a,
like New Year's Eve bullshit.
Really the end of the day,
who cares,
you know,
it's just another day,
man.
Like what?
What is in your butt?
Rituals as I'm getting older and more
experienced,
I used to reject anything that was
established because of my life wasn't so
good when I was growing up and I thought
that everything that was everything that
everybody wanted and everything there,
but he's working for.
It was all bullshit.
Degrees are bullshit and rituals are
bullshit and fuck you.
I'm a rebel.
I know I can appreciate that perspective
should be told.
But as I get older,
I recognized the benefit in like a new
beginning in your mind,
like this year I am going to do this.
This year I'm going to like how many
people.
It's hard for people to actually re
tweeted something today from Neil
Strauss who's a really brilliant guy and
a,
it's an article that he wrote about
strategies and systems that you can set
up to,
uh,
make sure you don't fall into the same
traps and sabotage yourself.
Cycles.
Yeah.
Which a lot of people do,
but you don't have to be the idea.
There it is right there.
Why you need a Ulyssa strategy for 2016,
the eye people have this thing in their
mind that this new,
this new day in this new time is going
to be the start of their new diet.
They're going to quit smoking.
They're gonna start exercising.
They're going to get their life in order
and they go at it with this,
these ernest's intentions,
but very few continue that process.
And the problem being we are creatures
of habit and we have these comfort zones
and we've sort of set up and when you
set up those comfort zones,
you set up these established patterns.
It's,
it's very easy to fall right back into
them.
It's very easy to be lazy.
But John Lilly that was studying like
the different levels of consciousness
that he himself said that there are
these,
these cycles that you have to try to
make yourself conscious of and try to
break these cycles and like,
um,
I know I myself find myself too often
sitting in a bathtub feeling a pretty
down on things and I'm like,
you know,
maybe if I get out of the fucking
bathtub,
go for a jog or so I wouldn't feel like
this.
Right.
It definitely would help.
Going for a jog is one of the best piece
of advice anybody could ever give you.
Have you ever have something that's
fucking with you?
Just go for a run.
Get those endorphins flowing and get
that blood pumping and put things into
perspective.
Your mind starts to change immediately.
You actually start the language that
your,
that your mind beats the shit out of you
with changes and suddenly you start
getting resolved and answers to your
problems versus like dwelling on them.
I,
myself personally,
I have gone for runs and I don't run
that much but.
And I ride my bike like in in the dark
when I'm amidst the darker depths of
hell.
And every time I come back saying thank
God you've went and did something right.
Well,
I think we associate as a human being.
We associate dilemmas and physical
problems like issues like bills or
lawsuits.
In your case.
All these,
we associate those things with a
physical thing because our bodies are
used to any fear or danger from the time
we were monkeys.
It's always been a physical danger.
There's never been like a social issue
until recently.
I mean the last few thousand years when
human beings start talking to each
other,
the real problems that we had were all.
They weren't fucking bills.
It's more instinctual almost looks like
there's a physical problem.
So when you develop stress and anxiety,
you have this physical response to that
like Holy Shit,
what's going on?
And then you don't do anything with that
physical response.
That physical response never gets fed.
He never run.
You never exercise.
He never exert.
And so your body just gets into a deeper
and deeper level of funk and stress and
the physical exertion.
All that seems like a meathead thing to
say,
look,
you just got to go to the gym,
walk it off,
but you really do.
You really do.
And if you do do that,
you will feel better.
Like some of my favorite people are
people that do Jujitsu because judges
two is such a life and death struggle on
a regular basis with people you love and
care about.
It's a bizarre thing,
like,
you know,
when you roll with people that you love,
like your friends with you slap hands
and they tried to fucking kill each
other and you're going to war.
I mean,
it's exhausting.
So when it's over,
you're drained.
So other pole shit of regular bullshit
to seems way less significant.
You still have to deal with it.
You're still a person who still live in
the real world,
still have taxes,
still a problem,
still have lawsuits.
Yeah.
Your situation's very,
very extreme.
My situation is extreme.
In fact,
if you don't mind,
I wouldn't mind a sort of offering a
perspective of just how fucked things
are.
Yeah,
please do.
So shortly after I was on the podcast,
and I don't know if you recall,
you probably don't,
you see a lot of tweets,
but I tweeted you,
um,
video of the owner of marine land,
who is the man that's suing myself and a
number of other people to try to stifle
our advocacy and essentially punish us.
And the video was of him driving past
our home and uh,
you know,
I upload it to Youtube and whatnot.
And then shortly thereafter there were
more videos and then neighbors started
taking photos when I wasn't home.
So he drives by and just threatened you
may slows down.
Well,
I assume it's to intimidate my
girlfriend and I,
he has a history of doing this and I
want to touch a little bit on that in a
moment,
but I just want to give my example to
begin with.
Give this videos on youtube right now.
Yeah,
we see it.
Sure.
What's it,
what's your channel?
I wouldn't mind showing you a couple of
them,
just google John Holder j o h n h o l e
r and you'll get videos.
Footage.
I mean there's a pretty elaborate
history.
We've unearthed a lot about sort of how
he,
how he operates.
I'm getting a little nervous talking
about this jewelry now because I just,
I know the consequences of which are
going to cost a lot of money and cause a
lot of anxiety where I'm going with this
story.
But when is this fucking lawsuit get
resolved here?
Here's the video.
We're going to watch the video real
quick.
So this is you looking out the curtain.
So I live at the end of a dead end
street and across from me as the water.
It's a beautiful place.
I love it and he's trying to take from
me my home essentially.
But I saw him come by and he stopped in
front of my house.
I armed myself with my old blackberry
camera.
He went down the road and you see them
now coming back.
See speeds up and right here you'll see
slows right down and he just wants
intimidate.
Of course he had no idea that I'm there.
Of course I present myself and I'm just
like,
what you want bro?
And then there he goes.
So he drives off.
When you come there,
he drives off little pussy.
Yeah,
well that's the same push.
You like to put a lot of bullets in a
while.
He'd shot those dogs if you don't recall
my telling you a couple of dogs wandered
off to his property.
Boom.
Filled him with a shotgun pellets.
Anyways,
so he pulled.
Do you know that for sure that that's
his truck?
Absolutely.
And in fact we've got them in this new
vehicle as well as license plate.
The whole works.
The police in fact set up a surveillance
camera.
Two of them,
they caught him independently and,
and don't quote me,
but I'm going to call it 12 times.
The police refused to lay any charges
because they said a driving past
someone's home isn't technically is
criminal harassment.
Despite the fact that we were like
looked at the man suing us.
He's,
he's dangerous.
I mean,
I,
I knew the man,
at least historically,
they've had a shotgun in his vehicle.
He's got a lot of reason to not like my
myself and my girlfriend who's on any
given time alone in my home,
so nonetheless the police wouldn't do
anything.
We took that information and went to a
justice of the peace to try to lay
what's called a private,
a charge,
not a charge,
but we just want him a summons to come
into the court and explain this
behavior.
This is normally a 30 day process.
Marine lands lawyers managed to get in
an appeal to the summons,
which is largely unprecedented.
I mean,
I guess with,
I guess people with money can skirt the
law,
but nonetheless it took a year and a
half.
The lawyer,
the judge ultimately decided that this
issue shouldn't be decided in the
criminal court.
In fact,
it should be dealt within the civil
matters.
So he quashed the summons so the owner
didn't have to come in and explain
himself.
And now I'm waiting any given day.
Now because the lawyers in already
informed my other lawyers,
they're seeking a cost,
a motion where I'm to pay the legal
fees,
which they're claiming upwards of
$100,000
to have had to try to get this summons
against him.
His stocking leads to my trying to lay a
private,
a charge if you will,
or whatever,
private summons.
He gets it quashed and now he wants to
put me on the hook for his legal fees.
So he's just trying to drain you
financial.
It's a war of attrition and it's like
there's just trying to crush anyone
that's showing any type of opposition.
Now I know the last time you were on you
have like a go fund me or something like
that.
People contributed to how do we,
how do we help you?
Wow,
what is that address?
And so recently I had to retain a new
lawyer to have my lawyers have left and
these were ultimately the ones that were
working really at a cost.
Effectively they're gone.
So I had to retain a new lawyer.
I don't ask for a lot of money from
people,
but I do ask for a lot of people,
as long as we've got money in our
lawyers can work,
this lawsuit has to run its course and
at some point,
and the judge has already said it's
already criticized marine land for
taking as long as they have now.
Marina wants to say,
well,
this is the behavior of the people of
the,
of the defendants,
the behavior being that we tried to seek
some,
some protection from this man that took
a year and a half.
He's trying.
The lawyers are trying to allege that
it's our behavior that delaying this
process and yet here we are two years
after I was here and not a single day
later,
of course,
a significant legal fees,
but we recently got a very generous
contribution from some animal rights
organizations that are running little
fundraisers for us.
Uh,
we used to have what you would call a
benefactor,
which was sam simon.
He's cocreator for the simpsons.
He was giving us a lot of money.
Unfortunately recently he passed away.
So that's sorta ended.
But yeah,
largely it's the,
it's the,
it's the public support.
This is really quite unprecedented to
have a litigation,
uh,
funded by crowdfunding.
It's really unheard of.
It's an important.
So what is the address and how do people
get.
We're going to put the address on
Youtube,
so if you're listening to this on
youtube,
it will be in the description of the
podcast and I'm also going to put it on
twitter and uh,
so we'll,
we'll have it as available as possible.
If we can put it in the itunes,
a description of the podcast,
we'll put it in that to what is,
what is the address and how do people
get to it?
Save smooshy Dotcom.
Smooshy being the walrus that had the
anomalous relationship with.
So it's s a,
v e s m o s h I.
okay.
Dot Com.
So,
so again,
I'm not funding just my own lawsuit.
I stuck my neck out and said I'm going
to pay for all these lawsuits.
Right.
Because for some years ago,
and I'd mentioned before that I won wipe
out Canada.
So there was a period where I actually
had a good chunk of change in the bank.
So when these lawsuits started to fly,
I just started cutting checks,
just start cutting checks.
Blow.
That didn't last very long.
Right.
So really it is the support of the
people.
But if you don't mind my touching a
little more.
Here's the,
here's the page.
Oh cool.
So save smooshy.
That saves smooshy.org.
Go to go to the Dotcom one.
Yeah.
What's the difference?
The differences.
That was just a website that I had
created for sort of like ongoing
fundraising and not exist.
Safe,
smooth.
No.
Put it all together in one word.
They're safe.
Smooshy DOTCOM.
It did.
It didn't work.
No.
It should.
That motherfucker close down your
website.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's trying to shut down my twitter.
Nevermind it.
Is He.
Okay.
Here we go.
Save smooshy.com.
What is it?
It had needed www dot.
Well,
it forwards to a gofund me.
That's probably why it needed a ww.
Um,
defend animal abuse whistleblowers.
So right now you've got some donations
and there's a donate button.
Donate on.
You can share it on facebook and uh,
let's,
uh,
let's fucking pump this up just to
stress that that's in Canadian currency.
Not to scare anyone because a lot of
people go and just like,
well,
what's the seat next to the donation?
You guys just stop using your bullshit
money and use ours.
Cut it out.
It'd be nice.
Yeah,
that's for damn sure you're connected to
us.
Let's cut the shit.
Goddammit.
Mexico to cut the shit with your pesos.
If I can just touch on
a story that I think it's important in
the realm of public opinion to,
or rather consciousness to know of,
but this isn't the first time that the
owner Marineland has stocked and
intimidated people.
In fact,
uh,
some years ago,
a woman named Paula Miller was living in
a trailer park that the owner marina
actually owned that was across the
street from the park and he had promised
them all that he was not going to,
to,
to move them or displace them and this
was going to be their home for a long
time.
A lot of retirees there,
people put some permanent investment in,
in their properties while ultimately he
did elect to kick everyone out.
Uh,
he had the city support,
which is not,
again,
we're up against a lot of forces,
if you will.
Well,
one woman was having none of that.
She was,
she was refusing to move and the owner
would repeatedly drive by an
intimidator.
And ultimately what she did was she had
written on the wall,
she'd written John Holder made you get
exactly what you deserve tenfold.
And then she thereafter committed
suicide.
Yeah,
I think it's important to tell that
story.
I,
it's because,
uh,
it illuminates sort of who he is.
Yes.
Essentially.
Allegedly,
of course,
to say that,
well,
we're going to help you,
man.
We're to pump this fucker.
I've said it before and I'll say it
again,
like,
we're really still in this game because
of you
heartfelt appreciation for having me
back on.
It's a can't tell you.
And the timing is right because we have
a bunch of different motion dates coming
up and.
But I appreciate that,
but I also appreciate what you're doing.
I think that guys like you were super
important for this.
You,
you in particular,
you probably one of the most important
because this whole thing that we're
experiencing right now is essentially
our civilization is awakening to the
horrors of the past and we're doing
something that's really fucked up and
not right and we've been doing it for a
long time,
so we think it's okay because we've been
doing it for a long time and this is
sort of the same thing that they
experienced with slavery.
I mean,
slavery had existed for a long fucking
time and it took a bunch.
I mean,
people feel like you're exaggerating
this.
This is not slavery.
These are animals.
Nope.
They're insanely intelligent animals.
There are.
They're so much different than a fucking
puppy.
There's so much different than a
squirrel.
They have a cerebral cortex that's 40
percent larger than human beings.
We don't know why.
We don't know what they're saying.
We know they have an insanely complex
language,
but we don't know what it's.
We don't know what the meaning behind
the sounds are.
We don't know.
We've recognized dialects.
They have different dialects in
different areas.
We know that they speak differently in
different parts of the world,
and I can,
I can personally offer perspective of
having had a really strong relationship
with an animal,
like my anomalous relationship with
smooshy,
the Walrus,
and I'll just do a quick,
uh,
summary of it is that she at one point
believed that I was her mother.
I mean,
she still does.
It's an eight now.
She thinks that I'm her mother.
It's tattooed on her brain,
right?
I've imprinted on her,
uh,
so I got to appreciate what it was like
to raise this animal in that unique
opportunity and in that the language.
And I wish Jonsi lily would still be
around because I think that he himself
will be calling a lot of bullshit on
what's going on.
He'd say,
this is a fucking catastrophe that
during your,
your what's being imposed on us,
the separation,
everything else.
But I got to learn what it was like to
teach an animal,
to have a sense of humor.
For instance.
I mean,
this Walrus has a sense of humor.
This walrus knows me intimately.
Whether I raise my voice or I lower it,
she has,
she knows me in the,
in a second dog.
Now I'm going to say,
I'm going to say for outside,
this is an animal that could appreciate
when there was real threat against me
and we used to joke around that and the
way that we discovered that she was so
protective of me that people come really
close to me.
She would beat the snot out of these
people.
I mean she'd come into like a 200 pound
bowling ball and displace you,
but she knew when I was messing with
someone or when someone had grabbed me
and it appeared to be a little more
violent.
It was mean.
Her reaction is someone grabs you in a
violent way.
The owner's son in fact.
And uh,
yeah,
the owner's son came over one time.
He just didn't believe what was going
on.
And he grabbed me and he didn't grab me
in a smooth and fun way.
He grabbed me and shook me.
Smooshy never forgot his face.
A she'd fucking shoes.
There was a gap between associate
smashed up against those bars really
aggressively harping on him,
the yellow and everything else,
and even in the weeks and months to
come,
every time he'd come any,
any even remotely close to me are in the
room.
She was ready to pounce.
It was amazing.
How fast is a walrus pounds.
They can you call it pouncing?
I wouldn't call it that kind of waddle
right there.
Pretty fast.
There are a heavy animal.
Actually I can say that I've,
I've,
and not just myself,
another other former trainers have
actually rescued the owner of marine
land from,
uh,
from Walter says that we're,
that we're about to attack them.
There's a video on youtube,
which is actually hilarious,
where,
uh,
he's out on stage,
obviously yelling at a trainer to bring
out more animals.
Everything in a Walrus,
breaks from them and starts going
towards the owner and he's turns around,
starts booking and the walrus stops and
he turns around and grabs his water and
froze the water.
And then the wall was,
goes and he sort of tucks away behind
this sort of safety door.
And I'm just like,
what a con.
I couldn't wait for him to get knocked
down,
man.
It didn't happen.
Whatever.
But there was a number of examples of
that.
Actually,
there's another video,
if you don't mind,
um,
look up.
If you Google John Holder again,
you can get to a place where he's
actually a confronting a,
an activist who's just,
they're offering on public property,
which has now since been leased to the
two marine land by the city.
Um,
he's handing leaflets with information
while they have a,
they have a conflict.
They have sort of a coming together and
uh,
John Holder in plain English threatens
to stab him and bury him.
And of course,
the activist,
who's Mike Garrett,
he's a fantastic guy.
Uh,
was um,
was,
you know,
he's like,
I'm assuming he saw us.
He tried to keep,
keep some sense and keep things as light
as possible.
But John just has a conniption.
He's yell and his arms and up.
I mean,
John's a little guy,
right?
He's got what I call it,
a little big man where he's just.
But anyways,
he goes all because the guy is
protesting against what we use the word
protesting,
but more than anything he's handing
information.
He's handing a history of marine landed,
but it happens to be at the end of the
park on public property.
But nonetheless,
you know,
uh,
the city obliged and leased the land to
them.
I mean,
it is what it is.
Greenland's operated for 53 years.
I'm above the law.
There was no loss.
There was nothing.
Now there are some.
Thankfully things are,
are turning slowly.
But if you could find that video,
if not,
that's all right Joe,
while I've got a while,
we're just here,
I'd like to show you this.
Oh yeah,
let's,
let's take a look.
So here he's like,
oh look,
we're hugging.
And then here
that little guys,
the little guys,
the owner,
and that's his hired gun on the uh,
right.
They're all it is,
is information.
That's all public property.
All we doing is asking.
People don't have to take it.
Whale,
whale and Nadia.
It's called me a whale earlier.
Let's stick with the program.
I can see John getting a little furious
here.
Thankfully.
Thank God John doesn't have a knife.
You all see very me right here as you
said.
When did he say that though?
You said it earlier in the video.
Oh,
let me hear the beginning where you said
him.
This is the closest I've ever been in my
life.
Like literally I come on,
he's just doing his job.
You're lucky.
I know.
I'm lucky you don't have a knife so you
would stab me if you had a knife.
Oh,
you kill me right here.
You would bury me right here.
You wouldn't even bother to look into
mass graves.
Come on up folks.
It's just information.
That's all it is.
Just information.
John doesn't want to stab me and
great guy.
Mike's a great guy.
I've tried to support him as well.
He's being sued.
Of course.
He's actually having his wages garnished
because marine land,
what they do is they use these lawsuits
and then they propose all these
different motions,
so it's sort of a function inside the
lawsuit.
Well,
what happens is during these motions is
it can go either way,
right?
A lawyer can,
can win a motion against another lawyer,
whether it be a bullshit lawsuit or not,
but what happens is in that process it
becomes a cost award.
So unfortunate for Mike,
he got a cost order against him and he
couldn't afford whatever the price was.
Of course,
Marineland we'll say an inflated price
prices.
All this costs $25,000 to have to bring
him in here.
And so the judge awarded $10,000.
So Mike's happens,
his wages garnished.
Now this is not a man who broke the law.
This is a man who opposed,
uh,
the policies and the,
and the practices of marine land.
This is because of this right here.
Because of that,
right there.
So he's having his wages garnished to
the tune of how much,
I think he said 30 percent a month for
how long or how much per paycheck?
He still knows quite a bit of money.
How much does he think he owes in the
arrange of six or 7,000 at this point.
And he just lost his lawyer.
We,
we actually had the similar lawyers.
He's,
he's looking for a lawyer.
So this is a public plea,
if there are any lawyers in Canada,
they're looking to make a name for
themselves and help our ourselves or
Mike Garrett like,
yes,
please get involved.
And if you do help,
I'll tweet it out.
If you do help,
I'll put it up online and I'll.
People know that you're doing
a good thing.
Joe,
while you're here,
I just want you to take a look at this
print we've had made.
This is from a,
a.
it's just an absolute sick graffiti
artists named Walk Brooklyn.
Save smooshy marine land.
Does that,
that teacher and this teacher that I'm
giving to me.
So I'll hold it up.
Yeah.
This is a courtesy.
Lofty Towers is a place in Niagara Falls
that,
uh,
generously printed it for us.
And then of course,
each one you've got to see this guy's
work.
It's fantastic.
And it's basically,
if you look at it,
you've got the wall,
you've got the Walrus.
Smooshy is basically giving the finger
to what appears to be an old man who's
with a shirt that says,
bury me with my money,
who's got some shackles around it?
And it says,
it sort of looks like it says fuck
marine land on the bottom.
I don't know if it actually does,
but um,
so that's the old dude supposedly.
I don't think.
I Dunno.
I have no idea.
Listen,
look like I'm good.
Totally not him.
No,
not.
Can't possibly be halfly.
Not Slave,
but there's a nice shirt for you to wear
it when you're doing some gardening or
raising your chickens in the back,
then I'll use that for sure.
It's much.
It's.
I hate hearing stories like that.
I hate hearing.
I hate hearing what's ultimately human
failure.
That's like a civilization failure,
societal,
cultural failure.
This,
this old creepy fuck that's getting away
with.
I mean,
you could just tell them that video is
disgusting and this whole thing is
disgusting.
Guy Wants to continue his slave business
and he's,
he's out there themselves getting his
own fucking hands dirty.
It's worth more money than I can even
conceive.
And yet all he wants is the power we
hold to like if I was worth that much
money.
Does he have a wife?
He has a wonderful wife,
in fact.
Yes.
Wonderful.
Yeah,
she's a,
she's a very nice going to say if I,
if I didn't Costa Rica about hookers and
coke until the heart stops.
He likes the hunt.
You'd think he'd just be able to hunt
steady,
like just go do the thing that you liked
the most,
but what he likes the most,
what appears to be is to be a tire.
You know,
I watched that episode of you and Lance
Armstrong and I thought it was really
great.
It really humanize the situation he was
in.
But the thing,
the thing that he expressed the most,
uh,
the regret was when he ultimately was a,
was a,
I forget the word he used,
but like get throwing all these lawsuits
against.
Yeah,
he fucked up.
He fucked up that,
that was a fuck up.
But that was,
that would be 100 percent supportive.
Um,
that's the,
I mean cause you know,
it's like if you ever seen the bill burr
bit where he's on Conan or we talked
about it until it happens.
But I am learning about bill burr now.
Actually.
I find his comedy amazing.
It's one of the best ever that do show
that he's got half is so great.
I watched an episode the other night was
really good.
It's on Netflix folks.
If you want to watch it.
It's an animated series called F is for
family and he's just a great guy.
He's just,
he's the real deal.
Bill Burr is the real deal.
He's just one of the best guys ever.
And um,
he had this amazing bit about Lance
Armstrong being that like,
you know,
basically his,
his words are psychopath beat.
You're a psychopath,
like the whole fucking sports on
steroids.
They're all on drugs.
And it's true.
He became the face.
Unfortunately he was pegged being the
guy and I mean he had all the accolades.
He had the image.
So it.
And which also means you had the most to
lose.
But the thing that he expressed most was
he regretted on people's lives.
I mean,
he was trying to keep this whole thing
going.
This guy,
what he's doing is just normal.
It's what people do.
You know,
when power,
when people have established power,
they try to protect it.
He recognizes all the benefits that he's
had for that power and he doesn't want
to step down and relinquish it.
And also if he did,
he would have to somehow or another
admit that what he was doing was wrong.
And I assumed that marine land is still
making money.
Uh,
it still makes some money out a little
bit,
is it?
The balance is down significantly
because tourism is up in Niagara Falls.
But I think if you guys really want to
get a,
a,
a good perspective.
There was a podcast that I was recently
on called Canada land and it's a,
it's a big podcast hosted by an
investigative journalist,
a Jesse Brown,
and he's very meticulous and very
thorough in his,
uh,
in his work.
And he had,
and he detailed this exchange between he
and marine marketing.
No one put a name on it.
It's got to be marine lines.
Lawyers,
I don't know.
But nonetheless,
if you want to see how they operate and
how far they're willing to go to
suppress what I say and the information
that we provide,
do go to the candle and podcasts and
check it out.
Um,
they've threatened to sue him,
they vowed to suit to what they called
judgment,
and that's a quote.
Um,
but that's just the way they operate.
If you,
I mean,
you yourself,
Joe,
and I hate to say it,
but it would be a dream if they
threatened to sue you.
It's not going to happen,
but why would they sue me?
First of all,
I'm a fucking American.
You can't sue me.
The goofy kangaroo court.
He's a Dick.
He's suing Americans right now.
I'm trying to threaten them with that
and I'll drive by his house at Fuck,
how about that?
I'll just say nice things to him.
I want him to threaten him.
Yeah.
That Canada land podcast details at all.
It was well,
it was really well done.
I just think the whole thing eventually,
when you look at it historically,
I think,
um,
my friend Amber Lyon had a great quote
when she was talking about when she used
to work for CNN.
Um,
it's,
I love this quote.
It's being on the wrong side of history.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that's what this guy is.
He's on the wrong side of history.
Yet,
when it all boils down,
you're going to look like an ugly
monster.
Yeah.
I don't know what he's trying to.
What type of legacy is trying to protect
at this point in?
The funny thing is all of these make it
lawyers rich.
It's not making me broke.
It's not working.
I mean,
to a certain extent that doing old rich
fucks.
Do they sue you?
You know?
I mean,
that's common practice they have.
That's their avenue of getting back at
you for talking.
He exists in a different world.
He is an old man and he's born in a
world where there was no internet and
he's experiencing the ramifications of
this time that we're in and also the new
information that exists now where we
understand that these practices they've
been engaging in for decades are cruel
and inhumane and disgusting.
They're disgusting.
There's no other way to say it.
Yeah.
Captivity of
mammals like that.
It's fucking disgust.
I indeed.
Where's it going to go,
man?
Like what?
How long can this guy keep dragging you
around the courts?
Well,
unfortunately there was some changes to
the law societies laws and where it used
to be,
I believe three years of inactivity and
the lawsuit you can,
you can file a motion to have it thrown
out.
That's been extended as I think it was
march of last year to five years,
so we've got a lot of things going
against us.
So you have two more years of inactivity
before they could sue you.
I,
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm not a lawyer,
but this is my understanding of what was
an opportunity before that is no longer
there,
but the idea is at some point he,
he himself has to play by the rules of
the courts.
He's going to have to be examined.
He's the one that's got the information
that we want.
We want to go get that information.
This is information that marine land is
steadfast right now and isolating or
other insulating any type of,
of,
uh,
of witnesses.
I mean he himself as a witness to all of
the things that he's alleging against
that he should be the one that is
responding to the lawsuit instead.
They give us this,
uh,
this,
this glorified janitor.
Well,
what the fuck does this janitor have to
do with our lawsuit?
We want to look at your financial files.
You're claiming financial losses,
uh,
in,
in the region of what's the janitor?
What are you talking about?
So what marine land doesn't listen.
This shouldn't surprise anyone is rather
than be like,
okay,
look,
I'm suing you so you can take a look at
my files.
I'm going to present to you that the net
losses,
financial losses of that I'm claiming,
and then you're going to have to defend
against this information.
Well,
instead they,
they gave me this,
this janitor.
Well,
what the hell,
what the hell has that got to do with
anything we don't want to,
we don't want it gave you a janitor for
what?
Like to look through his that he's
gonna.
Give us the files apparently that we're
looking at.
That is going to give context to the
lawsuit.
It's nonsense Joe.
It's just another means that I have to
fight and spend a lot of money to try to
get to the,
to,
to the root of it all,
which is the legitimacy of the lawsuit,
which there is none.
I'm being sued for plotting to steal a
walrus.
That's what it's all about.
My last wanting to steal smooshy my
lawsuit is plotting to steal smooshy.
My girlfriend's lawsuit is defamation in
the sense that she expressed concern for
the lone remaining killer whale Kiska,
which was bleeding profusely from her
tail and hurt her or talk with the,
with the Toronto Sun or rather the
Toronto Star,
which is the newspaper that revealed all
the,
sort of did the investigation of marine
land.
So she's being sued and they had a video
and then the video,
you see the killer whale bleeding like
crazy.
I don't know how you can call that
defamation.
And then there's another lawsuit called,
uh,
that's a,
that's going against Jim Hammond.
He's a former land animal care
supervisor and he's the one that
witnessed John holders shoot the dogs on
his property for no reason.
I mean,
that can't be defended.
It's indefensible.
These were,
these were golden labs.
These are puppy dogs and coyotes and
these were his neighbors and the
neighbors were afraid to press charges
because they thought that John would sue
them.
They probably thought,
right.
I mean the police themselves said to me,
we can't lay this charge on him because
he's going to lawyer us.
He's gonna.
He's gonna lawyer up.
Oh God.
Yeah.
It's really a stone wall.
They're putting up,
so he just gets is just strategy.
He just sues a war of attrition.
He's got a suit.
Everyone and what?
I don't understand how the courts are
allowing him to sue for this.
This doesn't make any sense because it.
Because we've gotten nowhere in terms of
trying to prove the legitimacy of it.
It's just the process itself in and of
itself is,
is,
is punishing to people like me.
So his idea is not,
let's go to court.
It's let's put him through the ringer so
that he goes broke and ultimately the
only way I can get out of this lawsuit
was if I signed something,
say I'm not going to talk anymore.
Well fuck that.
I'm not going to not talk,
I'm going to continue to talk to talk.
I'm going to continue to get my ass on
these podcasts and spread my word and I
get a louder and louder voice.
I mean that's my.
That's my resolve.
So you think ultimately this has to
somehow or another come to a trial?
It absolutely has to.
Or he has to drop the charges and then
he would have to get him.
I am suing him.
He's yet to respond to it.
This is something again that normally
lawsuits have 30 days.
This has been three years and they've
not responded well,
how's that work?
That how come you have to respond?
But he doesn't have to respond.
They've.
What they've done is essentially,
or what I believe they've done allegedly
is they've hijacked the process is what
it's called,
where you just inundate the courts with
a bunch of different things and every
time a court date seems to come up,
it gets adjourned or we do.
In fact,
I mean recently I lost my lawyer.
He's moved away so I was having to find
another one.
Marina and pounced immediately called
for a motion.
All of a sudden,
okay,
so now I'm defending or rather it
happened to my girlfriend and she got a
had to go in,
but my court date ultimately did get a
journal because my girlfriend was
successful and actually having the
motion to adjourn despite the fact that
they're continuing with these motions.
It's hard to explain.
I'm not a lawyer.
I can't really get down to the nitty
gritty of it all.
I can only just offer you the
perspective of someone who's being
punished unjustly with,
with a,
with a process that just in an is
inherently a abusive.
It's an abuse of process.
It's really discouraging it.
Welcome to my world,
man,
and I'm still trying to put food on the
table.
I mean actually got a life to try to
live.
I mean here I was 30,
35 when when this thing happened,
I'm 38 years old.
I'm going to sweat so I get to look
forward to resetting my life and try to
pursue some personal endeavors.
At what 45 is that?
When is that?
When I finally get to be freed of this
thing,
I mean I'm an activist.
Yes.
Okay.
Call me an activist,
but you know,
when this is all said and done,
I'm also a human being that wants to do
stuff in life.
What are you doing for work these days?
Um,
I do some.
Uh,
actually recently I was a pallbearer for
hire.
That was interesting.
A lot of people don't have families,
so I'd get a call and say,
you want to come help carry this casket?
Christ carrying dead that,
that'd be great for the book.
That's another thing.
That's the problem in the book.
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
That's a problem.
Well,
it's a problem because getting a
publisher's tough right now.
I mean,
if you're going to publish my words,
you're going to be sued.
You know?
I assume there was a documentary that
was in its initial stages.
It is gone.
There was a big story in outside
magazine that was coming out.
This was,
this was the feature piece.
It got quashed.
A lot of people show fear when it comes
to lawsuits.
Thankfully Ontario passed what's called
anti slap legislation.
We got the thing,
and I'd mentioned this in the earlier
podcast,
we were getting anti slap legislation.
The problem is,
and there's a major conflict of
interest,
is that Ontario's premier,
she herself had a slap suit against one
of the,
uh,
mpps during the elections.
She launched the lawsuit so that they
couldn't talk about this controversial
issue which was this gas plant scandal.
And so what she did when she
reintroduced the bill is that she took
out the retro clause.
This was our home run dude.
We were out,
not only that,
marina was going to be up against a
major punitive damages,
like as per the letter of the law,
they took out it being retro.
It's no longer retroactive.
It doesn't apply to us.
It's insanity because this one woman,
while she's the premier of Ontario,
fuck her,
I can't say that.
That's not going to help me.
What's her name and appreciated Kathleen
Wynne.
Fuck you,
Kathleen,
dare you.
I dare you remember I didn't say that.
How dare you felt if I didn't say it?
God Damn it.
It's cruel,
man.
That what I've come to learn and
involving yourself in any type of
government process and everything else
is that it's a thankless work.
It's fucking brutal and it rarely to
ever actually goes your way.
I swear to you,
I've had an arrow striking the bull's
eye and every time it just glances every
fucking time,
but I'm not discouraged.
Look,
I'm on this fucking show,
man.
It's a dream come true.
It happened again.
I cannot fuck a believer,
so a good things to come.
I just gotTa keep focused.
Good things to come.
It's just so bizarre that no one from
the government recognizes what a
horrible thing this is not just in terms
of the injustice that is being done,
but also in terms of the pr for their
legal system.
It is recognized.
It's large.
It's been expressed in a at Queen's Park
and provincial legislation.
These are abusive lawsuits and like we
had a,
an MPP standup,
Sherry Denovo and she's just like,
when is this gonna stop?
I mean she's pounding her fist and
everything else and what happens one?
Unfortunately she's.
It was a political issue and she's not a
member of the Liberal Party.
She's part of the New Democratic Party
and that's the.
That's a,
you guys have a liberal party.
We have various.
We have a liberal party that's in power
across,
on both the federal and provincial
legislation.
Your king is a liberal,
right?
King the King Justin Trudeau.
Yeah.
I like that guy.
He's the one that's going to legalize
marijuana in Canada.
Who seems like a cool guy.
I've heard.
I've seen him talk.
I'm like,
I wish we had a candidate for the United
States president like that.
He's the one who were trying to get
attention to see if we can't get support
for this.
Uh,
for this bill.
We're getting the Benne,
the whales and dolphin captivity.
He definitely should be a part of that
and he definitely should step in and do
something about what's happening with
you.
Have you guys tried to contact him about
that?
Uh,
I've not,
but that's it.
This is something that's governed with
by Ontario provincial.
Yeah.
So he,
there's nothing he could do about that,
but he's the king.
He's the king.
Yeah,
that's right.
Heavy is the crown.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
You can't just step in.
You'd think you'd tap on the shoulder.
Now granted,
uh,
I remember touring a lot of public
figures and intern during my time at
Marineland,
including John [inaudible] who was a
former prime minister's son who still
goes there.
So there's still some government ties to
marina.
Of course.
I'm still goes there like he visits.
He brings some people to Scuba dive with
the,
uh,
with the Beluga whales,
people,
people with disadvantages physically and
stuff.
It's,
it's a great program.
But uh,
that I know of.
He was continuing going up until 2012 at
least.
I don't know that he still goes,
I haven't been in the park in that long.
It just seems like Canada has so many
great things going for it.
And when I hear lawsuits like this and
that are so insane,
that lasts for so long.
And then that your counter lawsuit
doesn't get any traction at all and that
no one's paying attention to it.
I just don't understand how they can
allow that to happen.
That's a good thing.
There's a lot of people helping us,
right?
I mean,
because it appears that it's going to be
the will of the people versus the
government.
Yeah.
Fuck man,
I don't discourage me man.
I know that.
I know how I'm.
I hold.
I might hold deep and Shit,
man.
I know.
It's just,
uh,
it's so frustrating.
It's so frustrating as an observer,
as an outsider looking at this and
saying,
man,
this is just so strange.
It's so strange that in this day and age
this can happen.
Then someone can get away with this.
He hasn't gotten away with it yet.
I ain't done.
But he's getting away with what he's
doing so far.
So where,
I mean literally the government should
shut him the fuck down.
They should have stopped this lawsuit.
They should have been forced to your
lawsuit against him.
They should arrest him for stocking the
whole deal.
The whole deal.
It's just,
it's all disgusting.
I've become quite jaded and admittedly I
believed even when we came out that
there would be some type of justice.
I mean,
that's what we seeking.
Of course,
right.
Isn't doing this for shits and giggles.
Money is draining that justice.
When you speak to power,
you can expect some serious
consequences.
It's a simple as that,
but it's so insane that the charge is
attempting to kidnap a Walrus.
Correct and trespassing.
And here's the challenge,
and I offer this to all your millions of
viewers and listeners.
You find a single video of the last day.
I can't remember.
Shit,
I think it was April,
I think.
I believe it was a.
oh shit.
Why do I not know the date of this?
Let's,
uh,
let's call it October 17th,
I believe.
Two thousand 12 marina alleges that I
broke into the park with these legions
of animal rights activists,
which,
which actually did happen.
Not I wasn't there.
I was on public property.
I did not go into the park,
but you know,
hundreds did actually storm the gates.
And what marine line alleges that I
trespassed in there and there's tons of
videos.
I mean you can get 15 different vantage
points.
If any single person finds me in that
video,
I will personally cut you a check for
one point $5 million dollars.
That doesn't get you to have one point
$5,000,000.
How would you offer one point
$5,000,000?
I'll blow you auntie.
Well,
it's not going to happen.
Right?
So it was guy about it.
There's no video.
They're going to photoshop you and then
just for a blowjob,
I was going to someone to use that CGI
shit they did with Avatar.
I think I can negotiate my way out of
it.
I'll get one point five my hand job
marilla and thinks they're getting point
five out of me.
That's what they want.
One point $5 million out of the other
guy who essentially is,
but put it this way,
but they're trying to sue you for one
point $5,000,000.
Yeah.
That's the damage that they're claiming.
What's that in real money in terms of
like outside of Canada,
like America where accounts.
Oh,
let's call it a million bones.
That's a million bones.
Your money's worth more,
isn't it?
Right now?
Or significantly less.
What?
I'm drinking three beers.
I can while I'm here.
Well,
we'll send you some things.
I don't think it's legal.
You send beer across the border.
Probably not.
It's probably a drug is a drug.
Well,
we'll see what Justin Trudeau can do
about man.
So,
um,
have you gotten any traction on any
other shows?
Like any,
uh,
anybody else reached out to you?
That Katelyn podcast was timely and big
and it was great.
They get a lot of downloads and it's
still going.
It was published two weeks ago.
Okay.
So is Canada land,
is what it's called?
Yeah.
And do you know what episode it is?
It's called Marineland.
Okay.
Everyone loves Murraylands most recent,
uh,
send people to that.
What about a American podcasts of
people?
I'm Abby Martin,
thankfully has had me on a couple of
number of times and through the show
I've,
I've received quite a bit of support
from like what I would call some real
bad ass.
Awesome people.
So I'm,
I'm most appreciative.
But beyond that,
no,
there's,
there's really quite a bit of fear of,
of,
of my speaking.
So there are mostly in Canada,
right?
Uh,
mostly in Canada,
in America,
outside magazine,
they quashed that story.
I mean,
there's gonna be a big feature.
How did that happen?
Do you know?
So,
yeah,
so the,
uh,
the writer was staying at our place and
at the time,
uh,
I believe we had a,
there were,
um,
there were people watching us and I had
specifically said because his,
his rental vehicle was parked across and
here he was sitting on the couch and,
you know,
we're talking and talking and I looked
and it was a truck that repeatedly drove
by and stopped and went to the other
industry,
turned around.
I said,
fuck,
you're being,
you're being watched.
Like,
and he's just like,
you know,
I think at this point he didn't truly
appreciate the depths that we were in
and at this point I don't,
we weren't even sued yet.
And uh,
sure shit,
marina named him by name the author and
uh,
and that was it.
So he,
he,
he wouldn't,
I mean,
he,
he tried to get the,
the,
the article to run,
but outside ultimately said,
we're not interested in being sued now
it's a different time.
There's anti slap legislation now,
so outside if you're listening,
but well,
why didn't they just shut their fucking
mouth until they published it?
A he was.
How did they find out what he was
looking?
He was asking a current and former
employees to see if anyone would speak
and then obviously there was someone
that went to,
you know when you live,
when you worked in an oppressive sort of
regime,
if you will,
you're quick to try to score bonus
points.
I assume the former trainer or someone
probably said,
hey,
this guy's calling around looking for
something.
What other businesses that guy have?
They're all in house businesses,
but yeah,
he's got.
He owns a lot of property.
He does.
He owes no one any money.
There's no outside a financial interest
whatsoever.
He is the sole controlling mind.
It seems like God like that needs to
come to Jesus moment.
We're just realized.
It was like,
what am I doing?
My life is.
I mean he's at the later stages of his
life and just living like this.
So when people talk anger and evil,
and I hate to mention it,
but a couple of years ago,
a few years ago,
and this was my greatest ally,
his son actually passed away and this
was the guy who actually allowed into
the park when I went unbenounced to me,
I was no longer allowed there.
He let me in and that's when I saw,
you know,
smooshy in the condition that she was in
that ultimately inspired me to sort of
speak out and not be anonymous.
And uh,
he shortly thereafter actually passed
away and he was my age.
How did he die?
I had,
I'm afraid to say,
but I'll say that it was,
I would,
I believe it was avoidable.
I think that when you live under an
oppressive and difficult situation,
especially with regards to your
relationship with your father,
that maybe you resort to methods to,
to ease that pain maybe so to,
to sort of a,
I don't know,
maybe forget your woes.
So something drug related.
I don't know.
You don't know.
Okay.
I understand what you don't get.
Cheers.
Cool.
Thanks.
So I'm.
So what's the next step?
Like what happens now,
other than the next step,
tell everybody to go to save
smooshy.com.
Throw some money around.
The next step would be nice if maybe
Peta would step up.
I mean in terms of hypocrisy.
Peter likes to use our headlines and to
raise money for themselves on their
websites and they'll donate here.
Look,
how do you say Murraylands animals
donate here.
We have not received an iota of help.
In fact,
I asked them,
look,
can you,
can I just get a tweet out of you guys?
And they said,
Oh,
it's a nonprofit.
We've learned that.
That doesn't help.
Wait a minute,
hold on.
So they say donate here to them to help
you and the money to them to help them.
They know they don't.
They don't ever say to help to help you.
It's just that they use that stories.
They'll be like,
oh,
mass graves found out marine land and
then you know,
there's the article and it's whole.
It's horrifying.
Filled the says donate here and the
donate.
Donate,
Here's the donate to Peta.
Yeah,
it's tough man.
Well,
they're too busy killing cats and dogs.
And tweeting you on Orca Day tweeting
Joe Rogan,
the guy who's,
who's throwing arrows into every animal
that,
and they're asking you for retweets.
I thought,
I actually thought that was brilliant.
I'm like,
wow.
Pete is like,
really?
Uh,
they're,
they're showing their true colors,
but well,
they know that I do love orcas.
Yeah,
fair enough.
Just love to eat deer,
right?
Fair enough.
I don't throw ours into everything.
Not only edible stuff,
but I mean,
they,
they've,
they've retweeted things that I've
posted up about,
um,
about orcas and particularly about my,
my low thing of orchid captivity.
And I think there's new laws had been
passed in California,
right?
So recently seaworld.
So what happened with seaworld,
they had to ask permission from the
California Coastal Commission for a
$100,000,000 expansion of their pools of
the existing pools.
What they've said is,
we're going to eliminate the show,
which is not true.
That's not true in any capacity.
What they're going to do is create a new
environment.
The larger one,
which is good,
but they're still going to have a
presentation of sorts.
It's going to rely on,
you know,
animals performing more natural
behaviors,
but still is going to be food
deprivation in the train and it's going
to be,
you know,
it's the same thing.
It's just,
it's presented differently.
So what the,
what the California coastal commission
said was,
look,
we'll,
we'll grant you permission to make this
large expanse,
but you can't breed a orcas anymore.
So what seaworld basically said was,
okay,
well a,
they've,
they've considered not doing it
altogether be now they're suing the
California coastal commission alleging
that they've,
they've overstepped their boundaries,
but what's really.
So they want to keep breeding them.
Exactly.
Doesn't that tell you everything?
They're all of a sudden they're not
gonna going to create this large habitat
for the existing animals that they
supposedly care so much for.
But if there's that clause for breeding,
not they're not going to do it.
I mean that says it all.
Really?
It does.
Wow.
So they're not going to create the new,
larger environment just because they're
not allowed to breed them because
they've got this clause.
Well,
they're going to sue,
I assume,
to try to have that overturned where,
which I hope the California coastal
commission would reconsider their,
uh,
their approval of.
They should step it up and just make the
whole fucking thing illegal.
Jerry Brown,
come on.
you're a hippie.
There is a,
there is a recently tabled bill,
which is a federal ban across the states
for a Orca captivity.
They should,
they should.
One hundred percent.
I mean that.
I wish there was a way that they could
hook up a fucking machine to a pond or a
pool or an Orca is and have that orchid
communicate and have it broken down to
English.
Now we have google translate for Russian
and Spanish.
How about an orchid translate?
If they've,
if they figured out a way to
scientifically without debate,
analyze the sounds and break them down
into an English language that we could,
could read and understand that people
would be mortified.
Oh my God,
what if work has just started saying
really racist shit.
Just hate Chinese people.
Well,
they have reasonably well.
Maybe not the Orcas,
dolphins and whatnot have reason to hate
the people of Japan who are just
repeatedly a hacking them up.
And then of course in the Faroe Islands
where,
and I watched the video of our
documentary on what's called the grinned
is when they,
uh,
they,
they do these drive fisheries,
what they do,
they drive the animals,
their sonic animals,
so you know,
pound the bottom of the ocean floor or
these metal rods into other steel
structures.
And then the herds,
the animals onto the land.
Well,
what they do here in the Faroe Islands
is they grabbed these hooks and they
embed it in the fucking blow hole of
the,
uh,
of the pilot whales for instance.
And there's a long rope and then the
people drag these things up and then
they go up and then hack their throat,
right?
They want to call it substitute
subsistence hunting.
But it's hard to call that subsistence
hunting.
Maybe historically it has been,
but it's pretty brutal.
So they eat the pilot whales,
is that what it is?
They eat the pilot whales.
Yeah.
But if I,
I'm,
I'm of the opinion that it's,
it's a,
it's a cultural thing and they're on the
wrong side of history.
Now you've done it.
It's done.
It's documented.
You've got the photos,
if you will.
The history's there.
Let it be there.
Keep it in the history books.
Well,
it's one of those things where if you
look at the environments where they eat
whales,
they,
there's people starving.
There's desperation in those places.
I'm not going to argue in subsistence.
Eating and hunting is important.
I don't doubt that.
But in the Faroe Islands across from
where they're doing the grind is a law
is a vast,
beautiful cityscape.
Like you can't tell me,
you can't just go grab a couple eggs and
a cellphone omelet.
I don't know what you're saying.
The Dolphin thing in the movie the cove,
which is what you talked about about
Japan,
they,
um,
they tried.
They were killing them because they were
eating the tuner,
right?
Isn't that the idea behind it?
They will use anything to defend the
culture of killing these dolphins.
But really it's fueled by the captivity
industry.
Those dolphins are invaluable.
And,
and places like,
and I'm not gonna say seaworld now
because it's been a number of years,
but they have,
they have historically acquired animals
from these drive fisheries,
but they buy these animals and these
hunters are driving around in fucking
porsches and shit.
It's not because they're,
they're chopping these dolphins up for
meat.
That's not,
that's not the,
that's not the thriving industry.
It's the captivity industry.
They're selling them when they're
killing all those.
Why would they kill them if they could
sell them?
Well?
Well,
because they're not aesthetically
pleasing.
They take,
they take so many of the animals,
they take the more aesthetically
pleasing.
What do they sell them for?
The,
you know,
the tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of dollars when they chop up
the dolphins.
And then they,
uh,
they,
whenever,
I guess they gave him the supermarkets
and whatnot,
but to give him the supermarkets are,
softens.
Yeah.
I've never been,
I've been in Japan and every dolphins,
but in Japan,
the dolphin they have.
I think that that's something that's
going away.
I think the,
the,
the new sort of generations of kids.
I didn't watch the cove because I didn't
want to see it because I've seen enough
youtube videos of it.
It's just,
it's horrific.
I can't watch burger.
I didn't know that they ate them.
Yeah.
Well,
and what we're coming to learn is that
there's a high levels of mercury and
this in the dolphin meat,
so they're actually,
it's actually poisoning people so that
people are really getting away from
that,
but more than not,
I think it's front to keep the captivity
industry going and to keep that money
there because they sell them to places
in China.
They sell them the places in wherever,
in in Japan itself,
and there's a lot of money that's being
exchanged between the facilities and the
and the hunters.
So outside of Canada and the United
States,
there's a bunch of places in the world
that still have those sort of marine
type shows.
China,
especially right now,
China is really starting to,
is like a burgeoning environment for the
captivity into.
So they're ramping it up.
They're there.
They're plucking elephants out of,
uh,
out of Thailand and stuff.
I mean,
I mean wild caught wild barn baby
elephants.
They're stripping them from their and
from their mothers and their shipping
them to these places in China.
Now the zoos.
I mean this is another thing that has to
stop now.
Right?
Trying.
Damn that dog festivals rough.
Yeah.
The Yulin dog festival.
I watched that the other day on TV.
There was some sort of a special.
This woman goes over there and it was
interesting though,
the way the Chinese people looked at it,
you know,
and it's hard to argue,
they're looking at the same way we look
at Bacon.
It offers great perspective for the
people that are,
for instance,
saying,
I will never fucking eat this dog.
Well guess what,
it's not any different.
It's no less a conscious being then your
pigs who are arguably significantly more
intelligent than,
uh,
than dogs or your cows or your whatever
it is what it is.
But it does offer a glimpse into the
hypocrisy of loving one animal and
eating the neck.
So I appreciate this thing.
Offers that context.
It's bizarre how we have these ideas,
these hierarchies of animals were this
one.
It's okay to kill an Itam.
This one that's not.
It seems more novelty based.
Really?
Yeah,
because I mean,
you can make a hell of a hell of a pet
out of a pig,
but it's less cute.
Well,
there was a guy who had a pig the other
day.
Where the fuck were we?
Um,
somewhere here in California.
Guy had a pig on a leash.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Well the dog is a dog and a pig and he
had the pig on a leash like,
well,
okay.
I don't quote me,
but the intelligence of a pig is,
from what I believe,
I remember they're very smart.
Ten year old or something human like my
kid because it's so much smarter than
the human mind fucking kid.
No,
there's supposed to be intelligent.
I don't know if there were like a 10
year old,
but they're supposed to be quite
intelligent.
It's hard to.
It's hard to quantify,
you know,
like octopus.
They're just starting to realize how
intelligent octopus.
Of course I eat the fuck out.
Was anxious.
Tuna,
tuna,
tuna or intelligent apparently.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
Really?
Well to some,
I guess wasn't smart enough to stay out
of the cans.
Cans of tuna room soon.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Are fucking.
The ocean's fisheries are decimated.
I think we've got basically an expiry
date of uh,
I think they said 2014.
I watched a documentary called end of
the line recently and they basically
said that 90 percent of the ocean's
fisheries are fucking gone in tune
especially is really susceptible to
extinction.
And that's just because we just overfish
over fish and the,
it's the methods that we do it.
And I mean you get these trout,
you've got these trawlers that are,
that are setting up nets to the size of
football fields and they're just
grinding the,
the ocean floor and it's just decimating
the ocean.
Yeah.
It ruins the bed,
the ecology as a whole.
It fucks up coral reefs.
Everything.
And what?
What can be done about that?
I mean they've got to leave it alone and
let these things grow back.
It all comes down to what you can do
with your wallet if you don't,
if you're not spending the money to go
to a,
you know,
a Nobu and get that,
uh,
that,
that piece of Tofu or rather that whole
shit,
that piece of tuna,
then,
uh,
then you assume that in some way,
shape or form that that's gonna,
that's gonna curb this behavior.
But there's got to be.
The problem is also that the ocean is
not like,
like if you're in a country in the
country establishes like bag limits on
animals,
they can keep the populations very
healthy.
Precisely do that with an ocean is
governing the oceans very aggressively.
Well,
if they were this whole thing in China
or Japan wouldn't be taking place with
the dolphins.
You want people that are doing it is sea
shepherd and unfortunately a Paul Watson
is considered a terrorist and a lot of
countries and can actually set foot on,
on sound,
on,
on firm land,
right?
Some countries funny.
He's the one that's being like a
demonized for,
for really trying to save the fucking
planet.
Well,
the one of the things they've done in
Japan where they've sort of skirted
around this whale killing thing is they
say that they're doing it for scientific
research,
but then they take these animals on
board and
they butcher them and they sell the
meat,
but it's so fucked up.
All they have to do is like pretend to
run a few tests and they've documented.
The Sea Shepherd has done that.
They've documented these whalers and
they're doing it in whale sanctuaries.
They're doing the places where it
shouldn't be done,
but it's not monitored by anyone except
for sea shepherd.
End of the world,
brother fucking.
It's not though because this is the
first time ever where people are wildly
aware of this kind of activity and this
is where I credit this show.
I'm telling you,
I'm sitting here before you as a fan,
first and foremost,
you've illuminated so many issues and
like broadened my spectrum of my
consciousness so much I am.
Now.
I can tell you I am in the seat of that
of your millions of listeners.
I am that person right now.
St Himself.
Damn.
I wish I could be on that fucking show.
I just happen to do something that,
you know,
my,
my life circumstances just ultimately
led me here,
but I am that guy and I have to extend
another,
you know,
a big thank you for ultimately shaping a
paradigm that is shifting so God damn
fast and so many different levels and so
many different topics out there.
And largely what you did started what
six years ago,
I believe it was when you started the
podcast,
you know,
you're the guy who did this so well.
I couldn't have done it if it wasn't for
people like you being on the show
though.
Well all I'm doing is having
conversations with cool people.
It's this whole thing has made itself.
It's very bizarre.
I love that.
My ass is in some way of making physical
contact with some awesome assets that
have sat here.
Man.
You know,
we're sharing an interesting way of
looking at it.
I love it.
I love him running up against.
It's going on.
Be able to grasp radon.
He wasn't in that one that was old,
old seats already mentioned.
These are pretty,
these are dope,
right?
Yeah.
They are saying to Ergo depot for uh,
providing me with these,
these are called [inaudible] Pisco
chairs because people constantly ask me
on twitter.
There are super comfortable.
They're ergonomic chairs well to,
well they move well,
but here's the most important thing.
These are the only chairs I have ever
sat in that are comfortable that I can
sit for a three hour podcasts and my
back doesn't hurt.
It's got the lumbar support and yeah.
Well when I leave let's just forces you
to sit in a way where your direct,
which is how we're supposed to sit.
And when I would sit in like a standard
office chair by the end of the day,
my back is all fucked up from Jujitsu.
So like the middle of my back would be
hurting like hell leave podcast and I'd
be all stiff.
I leave these like I like,
I just like I feel right now like I just
sat down like it doesn't bother me at
all.
Yeah.
Full disclosure,
I was moving in my seat because I'm just
fidgety guy.
Comfortable these ergonomic chairs,
man,
they are the future.
They are the,
they are the present there,
there,
there is so much better than a regular
office chair.
Regular office chairs cause you to sit
in as sort of a weird way unless you
consciously like I need to get these
fucking things to the UFC because when I
sit and watch the UFC for six hours,
I sit like a hot chick on instagram.
Like when they stick their ass out.
That's how I sit.
I've purposely forced myself to sit in
this unnatural way.
Whereas if I had chairs like this,
I would just uh,
yeah.
So ergo depot Holler at me,
we'll send these bitches over to the UFC
and the UFC has um,
you know,
they use the chairs that are there at
the Mandalay bay or mgm or whatever.
But my point is these are the shit.
Yeah,
the great.
Um.
Anything else before we wrap this thing
up?
Everything else I could talk for hours,
man.
Wrap it up and let him do anything else
important that we left off the table.
Oh Shit can.
I know you got a whole notebook there,
dude.
You're like a comedian.
You have like notes.
It's my process.
Oh,
AG gag laws.
You're familiar with ag gag laws is
agriculture laws that a factory farming
and the perfect example of what we're
going through.
This is a microcosm of what we're
dealing with.
Greenland sort of gets creative and sort
of creating their own little law,
the Ag gag sort of procedures with
existing laws,
but yeah,
these ag gag laws are just a.
just an absolute.
Just the fucking horrible thing.
I mean to to to be able to prosecute and
punish people that are trying to expose
the truth of farming and agriculture
practices.
This is absurd.
This is fucking crazy,
right?
Yeah.
Well what they're doing is if people
have a video,
like a cell phone video or something
like that,
and you film pigs in captivity or
chickens or anything in agriculture
where they have factory farming,
you can get sued and you can go to jail.
Like you can go to jail for exposing
something that makes people sick and a
reality of business.
If you're buying something.
I feel like if I'm buying a chicken and
then I find out,
oh,
I can no longer be detached from this
process because now I know exactly how
this chicken left and I feel horrible
about it.
I've been educated and so that company
needs to change its practices because I
don't want to buy chickens from them
anymore and if some people do,
that's fine with them,
but to stop people from filming that and
showing you what you're trying to keep
people in the dark or misleading people,
what you're,
you're,
you're hiding facts,
you're hiding truth.
That's not cool and this is exactly what
we're dealing with in reality.
Right?
It's the same fucking thing.
Yeah,
it is.
It is.
It is exactly the same thing.
Hiding truth,
hiding reality and,
and,
and trying to keep people from being
aware of what's essentially torture.
You know,
I buy as little meat as possible and no
eggs.
I don't buy any eggs from anyway unless
I'm in a restaurant or something like
that.
For your own chickens.
I have my own chickens and I,
I have like,
I've,
I have a good feeling.
I my chickens,
like me,
they come to me like I come out to them
and I bring food and like what's up
kids?
Hey girls and I put the plate down
there.
They're not scared of me.
They run over and they lay eggs and I
take the eggs.
Sometimes they pick on me when I tried
to steal their eggs but like reach under
them to take him,
but they barely know me.
That could,
you could take them,
but my point is it's like I enjoy that
relationship and I know that not
everybody can have that sort of
relationship,
but that is what you want.
If you want eggs,
like Peta has these really ridiculous
campaigns against chickens and against
eggs where they call it a chicken period
and they have a frying pan on their
website with a pair of panties that has
like a,
a fucking bloody spot on the panties and
you're frying the period.
It's so bizarre.
Have you ever seen any Jamie?
Pull it up.
Periods tasted as good as eggs.
I don't think there'd be an issue,
but there is.
Don't do something with Jesus.
Come on.
How dare you take a penny?
What's the problem?
How dare you keep going?
Um,
the problem is captivity.
It's not eggs.
Joel Salitan,
who is a really fascinating guy.
I had him on my podcast and he's an
advocate of,
of what you would call natural farming
when he,
um,
has pigs,
what he does is he puts this enormous,
um,
electrical fence up and the pigs,
they don't want to go near the fence.
It's sort of,
it doesn't hurt him,
zaps them so they don't pass it.
And then they moved the fence so they
continue to graze and new property.
So they're eating acorns and roots and
all natural things that pigs eat.
And that's what he does with these pigs,
with chickens.
The same thing.
He has these enormous chicken houses and
they roll them to new environments.
And so on his farm,
this chicken house,
um,
the,
the Hen House has rollers on it and
they'll move it to a new area.
And the chickens,
my chickens,
I opened the gates and my chickens run
around my yard and then they go back in
the hen house at night.
It's what they do,
they so stimulating for them because
they get a new environment all the time.
Yes,
and they're free.
They're literally free and when you get
eggs from those kinds of chickens or a
dark orange,
like a really dark,
deep orange,
and that's because it's much healthier
than when you see something that says
like vegetarian fed chickens.
Guess what?
Chickens aren't vegetarians.
They're fucking dinosaurs.
I fed my chickens a mouse once and
here's another example of like the
hierarchy of animals.
We love animals we don't love.
It's really interesting how this
happened in my house.
My kids found a hawk.
The Hawk slammed into a,
I think a window or something.
Not sure we weren't there,
but we found this wounded Hawk so my
kids decided that we were going to do is
we're going to take this hawk and get it
to a wildlife rescue organization.
So they had to feed it because it was
over the weekend and the rescue
organization wasn't open,
so they went to the pet store and they
got the called Pinkies,
which are these little tiny mice.
Yeah.
For the people listening,
their mice that haven't their baby mice
and they use them to feed snakes and
stuff like that,
and so they fed the hawk,
these pinkies and there was one pinky
left and they got the hock to the
wildlife rescue organization.
The Hawk was taken care of and
everything and hopefully was released
into the wild,
but we had one pinky leftover.
My daughter wanted to raise it and I
said,
sweetie,
this is going to die.
It's not.
It has to eat milk.
It's only been alive for a few days.
It's just not going to last.
I'm amazed it's still alive and she was
crying and I said,
but we just fed them to the hawks.
Do you understand this?
I go,
there's one of two things we should do.
we should either bring it back to the
pet store.
No,
I go,
listen,
if we don't bring it back to the pet
store,
it's going to die.
We bring them back to the pet store,
the pets pet store.
I don't know if the mouse will accept
it.
Now that we've got our scent on it.
I don't know how that works,
but they're going to feed it to a snake.
There's going to resell that.
Someone's gonna,
someone's gonna buy it or it might die
because it hasn't eaten in 24 hours.
I don't know.
And our other option is we give it to
the chickens and they're crying and this
and at this point had you known that the
chicken was likely to eat this thing or
I've seen them eat a mouse before.
Really?
They're fucking ruthless,
ruthless.
Like I put that mouse down.
It was not down on the ground for a
fucking half a second when one chicken
slammed it grow,
got it in his beak and the other
chickens were chasing this chicken
around the cit.
The Hen house like this chicken couldn't
pause to try to eat this because all the
other chickens knew what had had and
they were running around.
He couldn't.
He couldn't stop.
It was running and it's trying to eat it
and the other chickens are running with
it and it was just.
I should've filmed it.
I had no idea to.
They're monsters.
They are with each other and they like
to pick the shit out of each other and
they pack everything.
Here's what's fucked up man.
They picked my daughter a couple of
times and one time I almost killed one
of them because it packed her face.
And um,
my wife is like,
it doesn't know.
I go,
listen,
it's trying to eat her.
It just can't.
Do you need to get this in your head.
It's not that he doesn't know.
It knows she's alive and it's trying to
fucking eat eater.
And if we held her down,
those chickens would eat her.
She's like,
you just,
you,
you get crazy with this.
I go,
I'm telling you right now.
They are fucking dinosaurs.
They are cold blooded.
There they have,
they have the fucking brain of a pencil
eraser.
Okay.
Little tiny on the tip of your pencil.
That's how big their fucking brain is.
Walk.
Fuck.
Fight.
Exactly.
They'll eat everything.
They follow my wife around like she'll
like lift up rocks and they dive under
the rock to try to get worms and
anything that's there,
the little predators,
man,
are straight up predators.
So when you see you like vegetarian fed
doesn't,
those are good eggs and not doing any
service to that.
They're omnivores,
they're omnivores and they would eat
meat all day long above grass if you
gave it to them.
They like that more like my lawn is
filled with grass and they pick up the
grass and they eat all kinds of other
stuff too.
And they eat the chicken food that we
bought.
We tried to buy the most nutritious
chicken food available.
There's some brands that are like more
more diverse and the the,
the,
the food and the nutrients that are in
them.
But the bottom line is they abandoned
all that shit.
When they see something live,
they'd try to eat living things.
That's what they want to do.
That's the thing we got to be scared of
most is chickens.
They're going to get big,
which is lucky.
The little.
Yeah.
Well you ever heard of terror?
Birds like to tell people that all the
time.
It's just like,
if you don't think that that cat
wouldn't fucking eat you.
If it was just a significantly larger
believe you'd have a different respect
for,
oh fuck you.
For a the ammo and the idea that eating
meat is.
Yeah,
dude,
fuck.
Like a large mouth bass.
Your swimming pool big enough for large
mouth bass teacher.
You're done like a group or have you
ever seen those groupers and Florida?
They would eat a baby.
One hundred percent gay babies floating
around group would come up.
There was a nutty video of a group or
eating a shark.
I saw.
Isn't that crazy?
I'm crazy.
The shark was like Three v swallowed it.
Just put her into jumper.
Mammoth fucking animal.
It's like a giant large mouth bass from
the hobbit movie.
It's crazy.
They don't even seem real.
I don't know how big they get,
but I think it's hundreds and hundreds
of pounds that massively.
This.
Here it is.
These people,
they caught a shark and they put the
camera in the water to film this group
or that's coming up to the shark,
so they have a small shark on the hook
and as they're reeling it in and they're
bringing it in and they see this video
could use some editing and as they're
reeling it in,
they've got this shot.
It's not a small shark,
it's about three feet long,
maybe even more.
I might even be four feet and this group
or comes along and some mashes it as
they're trying to get it out of the
water.
Look at this.
Boom says great.
I mean that group has got to be two,
300 pounds.
I don't know how big they get,
but I would assume they get to be like
three or 400 pounds.
How big your group is,
Jeremy?
Well now let's.
Let's end this with groupers.
Those they taste good though.
Do you ever have a grouper sandwich?
No,
I haven't.
I don't know if you would want to eat
it.
Old One like that.
Probably not.
Yeah,
they get a little.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's the case with
fish.
I know it's definitely the case with
Is it?
I go fishing.
You don't want to keep your 11 pound
Walleye.
You want to eat the like a three and
like smell really three pounds.
Why?
I went wildlife fishing for the first
time last year with good eating.
Anxious perch and yeah,
and Alberta.
Man.
How big they get two point five meters.
Eight feet.
Oh my God.
They can weigh as much as 790 pounds.
Holy fucking shit.
Wow.
That is insane.
I had no idea.
Eight feet.
That could eat you.
700 fucking pounds.
That is so crazy.
Wow.
I did not know.
They got that big.
Oh my God.
Eight feet.
Imagine Shaquille o'neal.
A foot bigger than him is a grouper.
That's insane.
Look at the size of that thing is one
with a dude.
Oh my God.
This thing is bigger than the guy.
Look at the little fishes thing on the
other side of the guy going like,
fuck no,
I'm not coming.
I was thinking I'd find you.
It's hoping that the group or like
taking chunks out of that guy and like
leaves a little for him.
God,
ocean is awesome.
The ocean is so amazing.
Deep Ocean.
The more you learn about it.
I mean you see in Japan that massive.
A massive squid.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
The swimming.
I don't want to swim anywhere near that
fucking thing.
That's a.
that's an evil Predator right there.
You didn't know when it gets stuck in
those tentacles.
Oh yeah.
They are really evil and they're so big.
They're the.
What's really nuts is that giant squid
were just a myth and a couple of decades
ago they had no idea if they were real
like they had.
They had never caught one of these
things on camera.
Now they have one.
It looked like it was in a base
somewhere because it was really close to
boats.
It was crazy to look to allowing people
to swim in it.
Like they never caught one before.
Like they didn't know if they were real
then catching them.
I wouldn't swim with that thing.
I want to have a catching them so
because they're catching them much more
frequently now.
Like look at it,
look at the video of it.
My God,
what an amazing,
amazing creature.
The entire body flexible.
Nothing but a beak like as far as the
only thing that's hard.
Do you know,
they found evidence really recently of a
gigantic,
some,
some sort of octopus type species that
would be like a cracking their thinking
by the size of the tentacles.
This thing would be 100 feet long and
they found these enormous tentacles that
were like,
you know,
dinner plates and they're,
they're saying,
okay,
well this is what the myths of the crack
and I've always been.
The crack was always this gigantic
tentacled monster that would eat
anything.
I look at that fucking well,
it's hard to perspective when you see it
with a person,
you get a real good idea of how,
how enormous it is.
But I think that thing is like 18 feet
long or something crazy.
But these crackings the.
There's nothing left of them when they
die.
So what they found is a fossilized
remains of the tentacles had dot when
they went into died,
the tentacles had left an imprint on the
ground,
on the bottom of the ocean.
And so that's the got the fossilized
remains of these tentacles.
They're like,
Holy Shit.
And they realized,
well,
okay,
well this is where these myths come
from.
This was a real,
a real creature.
It's amazing how little we know in terms
of what the deep ocean and has available
to it in terms of,
uh,
of,
animal life.
Oh,
it's crazy.
We're discovering stuff every day.
Yeah.
They say we know more about the moon
than we know about the ocean.
Well,
it's,
what is it?
Seventy percent of the earth or
something like that.
Something percent.
Some giant percentage of the earth is
water and the ocean floor,
I think they've only examined like five
percent of it,
which is amazing.
So 95 percent of this incredible,
essentially wild world.
Meaning it is a wild world and it'll
ultimately comes from the ocean.
The ocean is what gives us life.
That's where we have to respect.
Supposedly it all came from,
right.
We all started off somehow or another as
some little fucking fish thing.
I got to watch more cosmos.
That's another thing.
I can't get enough.
I know,
right?
I'm so glad they brought that back with.
Especially with Neil degrasse Tyson's.
Great.
Great podcast too.
It's called startalk.
It's awesome.
It's really good.
Definitely check that out and it's all
about a bunch of different subjects to
like,
he had a really cool one with David
Byrne from the talking hands about
creativity and he's just a really
interesting curious guy.
Neil degrasse Tyson had got a great
demeanor and I liked the way they do the
cosmos with the,
with the sort of,
um,
the,
the imagination and the animation,
the animation.
It's great.
It's awesome.
Great.
It's a very engaging.
Um,
so we're good.
Anything else?
Yes.
All that safe.
Smooshy.com.
Follow me at a.
You never know when that periscope
broadcast is going to happen.
You have periscope broadcast.
What do you do?
You never know.
You never know when that periscope
broadcast is going to.
So we should follow you on twitter.
Walrus.
Whisper on twitter.
Hit me up on facebook and periscope and
that's how I keep my voice alive,
man.
Well,
we're going to help you in.
We're going to help you keep your voice
a lot.
For sure.
I can't thank you enough.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Alright fuckers.
We'll be back tomorrow with a great
Thompson Guerra.
Until then.
Much love.
Bye.